e
good morning everyone the time being
hearings first I want to welcome uh all
the ways and means uh committee members
back for a New Year
2024 and I hope you all had good
holidays and a good start to the New
Year all right we um as you all should
know by now CRC cacr 15 was uh
cancelled um at the request of the Prime
sponsor and will be rescheduled to a
later
date so we will start with
ca18 and uh do we have the sponsor
representative saitis uh
introduce okay you
and thank you um I'm Katherine saus I'm
from Hillsboro
um division 7 and it's which is also
Nashua uh w s um I apolog iiz for my
speaking I had a stroke um a couple of
years ago and so sometimes I have word
finding
difficulties so um now this cacr is
you're probably asking yourself why now
why is this bill why is this cacr in
front of you and what I want to say it's
for the people that are not represented
in this
house the division of church and state
has become
blurred blurred blurred blurred in the
last four or five years and what I would
like it on the record that I am a devout
Greek Orthodox and so I am a Christian
but I I do not believe in the Christian
imposition onto public policy at all and
um I also function as a nurse and so uh
there is sacred space between a doctor
and his patient and I don't I don't
believe anybody it has the right to be
in that
and um there's a lot of Christians
non-christians in um New Hampshire and
nsha is a welcoming city that has a
mosque we have Hindus we have a lot of
different religions and the fact that
Faith groups are are um using their tax
exempt status to
reach I mean yeah they're they they get
to reach too many people and they have
too much political power and in a state
that runs as lean as ours that means
that when things are taken away from the
public to take to religious um
organizations to to uh determine public
policy Than People of different um Faith
or even atheists do not have the same
crack at the pie to
me because from the beginning of time
here the founding fathers have started
they started with the Treaty of Tripoli
to say about the separation of church
and state and as we grew up I remember
hearing about Roger Williams and I
remember hearing about the Pennsylvania
how they were quite firm about how they
didn't want churches and church and
state mixed together so part of this
goes into the
um into the part where um it said in our
um the money in the constitu of the
state would not go to religious
schools
so I have people in my ward especially
and it it really bothers me because we
have an elementary school that has
between 80 and 90% of the poverty-driven
children uh qualifying for free and
reduced
meals and
um at the polls and at other times when
we have meetings up at that school
people who are of the
um The Homeschool cow crowd and the ones
who want the public school vouchers tell
all the parents um this is a nasty
school it's a failing school and I want
you to know where you can get free
money and you can take your children out
of this this failing school and that
hurts me right in my heart because one
of the things that the founding fathers
did was say that everybody has access to
an adequate public education and so
when um you're taking money out of a um
public school to put into a private
school and it doesn't come back then
those people who don't have that same
power um are under represented by all of
us and so these are the reasons why I
want wanted to have this cacr because
not because I
don't understand and um respect what
faith-based groups do in the state of
New
Hampshire but I just want people to stay
in their own sandbox and stay in their
Lane stop dividing us up and um let's
all get along for the people that we
were elected to
represent and so it goes with bodily
autonomy it goes with access to
education there's a whole group of
people out there in this state that are
not being represented and that's my
testimony thank you questions
representative
plet yes thank you for taking my
question represents solitis if I
pronounced it right um or closely enough
yeah okay um you say that uh the public
schools are not taxable but the church
schools should be
taxable and the difference is what do
you just want to support the public
schools no I just think that the one
step out from them is where the the
public
schools um their parents pay taxes we
all pay taxes part of paying
taxes taxation is is not
theft and um I have heard that since I
got here but for me taxation
is
uh a sacred thing uh ability for a
society to work together and so when
people have a tax policy that there
should be no tax policy and that certain
groups get all the tax
breaks then um people are not being
represented presented properly and I
just think
that we need to step back a step from
the sound bites and for the things that
divide us and work together for sound
public policy for all and to remember
that there's a lot of people that don't
have represented re res representation
here in conquer and that's who this this
Aly thank you
on I don't quite see how making that
religions pay
taxes would empower the people in the
school and other people like them that
you're talking about on to to to be able
to advocate for themselves more but the
thing that most troubles me about this
is that uh we have a whole system of uh
not of nonprofits not paying taxes some
of the nonprofits seem to me a little
bit too stretched into things that
aren't helping anybody except the people
in it but we do have that and you're
carving out just the religious
ones and what where does that leave the
others thank you for the question I've
thought of you specifically a lot
representative Aly since um I um one of
your fan girls and I watch how you um
have run this committee when you've been
the chair and this is just a
start um that will probably go nowhere
quick but it's a part of a policy
discussion that leads to give and take
and to learning more and um I know that
it's probably what you would say a
frivolous um cacr and it's wasting your
time and I know that you do a an August
amount of work in this committee and um
and I deeply respect this committee and
I'm not here to disrespect anything and
I know that my knowledge of these things
is not deep but it's just my feeling
that since I've got to conquered um
seven years ago that it seems to me that
that my people in my district are not
being represented here and so this is
just an ask that we all consider
that that um people who have words that
divide us are very hurtful to people who
don't have the political power to um
speak for
themselves representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative uh one question for
you representative and then Mr chairman
I have a question for you uh does this
cacr inject other government rules and
regulations Beyond Health policy of the
churches no it would not Mr chairman uh
the question I have then is is the Dr
going to speak on this particular
resolution or cacr
today um if they if they would like to
or you would like them to we I don't
have a pin card because my question is
directed how much in state revenue would
be produced from local and state taxes
okay good
question uh representative
fellows thank you Mr chair um I I
support the general concept of with the
separation of church and state but when
I start to look at it at a detailed
level then I start asking questions like
there's a big private school at the end
of um my road that I live on and it's
it's goes back like well over a hundred
years and it's and it's was started by
the Episcopal church if you went there
now I I don't they don't even have any
you know they make the kids go to Chapel
on Sunday morning but um aside from that
but it's a big property and I'm
wondering if we're just talking about
the house of worship which would be just
just the church or um if we're going
getting into the things like where it
could be a school
and when it says um religious
organizations um you know that that's
kind of hard to Def to find and some
things could be go you know they are or
they're not and of course if this passed
what would happen is we would have to
develop rsas to answer these questions
but I think I would like to have a
better understanding of what it would
mean in the long
run yes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question so for hundreds of
years it was the churches in similar
societal groups that took care of the
poor and fed the poor and housed the
poor and if we were to tax these
institutions a lot of them their door
swings both ways so I don't know what
you mean exactly by staying in their
Lane I mean a lot of churches have
rainbow flags on them so do you really
want to tax these churches as you call
them I I would refer to them as Church
buildings if you're a Christian I'm a
Christian we're the church not the
building right and so are you in a
position then to pick up the slack and
the enormous resources it's going to
take for public schools and public
institutions to do the work of these
churches as you call
them um no sir I'm not what I
am is I'm
asking
the the people who look on the poor and
unrepresentative
represented is um less than or um making
their Church's
values reflect on how they feel about
people who are not me members of their
religion and so the things that the poor
have that they consider moral
failings and um
mostly this is a grand idea that I
thought in my head and it's kind of like
not
uh cacr so much as a
question follow up
please can I finish answering I thought
finish no I just think that
um the ask that that this body makes of
you every two years is to get blood from
a
stone and it's a very hard thing I know
it and so what I'm
asking because it's um I'm I'm on
invironment and agriculture committee
I'm stuck in the farms and in cow poop
so so for me to have a working knowledge
of what it is that you all do and you
see the bigger picture than I do this is
a question of how we can stop people who
have an
agenda from looking at other people with
the different
scope and um punching down on them and
and
um for
example where would we be in this state
if the governor of Texas puts a couple
of buses up
here I don't know but the way that that
people who are dividing us as a nation
from different points of view I just
want it to stop because it's getting in
the way of us taking care of everybody
else and so if everybody would come here
today and listen to this and they would
see that I am representing people who
are not not represented
here and maybe they could tone down
their rhetoric a little and we could
come together for the good of the people
of New Hampshire and that's a big ask
and I know that this is probably a big
distraction that this committee doesn't
need but I'm just asking that this the
the religious groups have so much
political power they have Deep Pockets
the money can come from out of States um
I myself have been doxed by a religious
um organization and I had pictures of my
house put on the internet with death
threats when I made an obscure comment
about moms for Liberty I had hate mail
from Florida um and I just want people
to stop you know if your first
reaction is something from your stomach
out through your mouth then this this is
not not a policy thing it's an emotional
thing and I want us to be more like
Susan El me and be policy driven let's
talk about the policy and that's what I
want follow up so uh thank you Mr chair
so you want certain churches to quit
beating down on people but the churches
are split the churches support the lbgt
community
so which churches are you going to shut
down with taxation I mean you're talking
about churches beating down not
representing people they represent both
sides of the fence so which churches do
you want to shut down first you want to
shut down the LGBT church or do you want
to shut down your church or
representative Oris let's keep the
questioning to the specifics on this
bill
please I'm I'm getting off all right
um hold on uh yes representative thank
you Mr chair um regarding uh taxation on
churches though it's also covered by the
the US Congress too and that might be
kind of difficult to allow for taxation
of U churches in the Hampshire when
we're against federal laws but um I got
to tell you I'm sympathetic with the
fact that um last session I put a bill
in with Su Prentice
to actually do a study committee on uh
nonprofits and I live in Plymouth and
Plymouth has uh greater than 53% of its
of its properties are owned by
nonprofits um and we have the majority
of Plymouth uh property owners that are
basically subsidizing both churches uh
schools hospitals
nonprofits and I would prefer actually a
bill ultimately to go in that would
actually allow for um um municipalities
to tax at some percentage every
nonprofit to include churches so I am
sympathetic with to the extent that
churches should not necessarily be
exempt thank you I am excuse me
representative Bolton is there a
question U would you you would you
believe that that's the case I would
because um in a state that's driven so
much by property taxes this was a big
year for property taxes to go up and a
lot of these buildings
um they're sitting on pretty valuable
property and I just I I guess I would
like for people to go back to where we
could uh we could chat on policy and we
could be the policy makers and that you
know when every dime
counts especially my property taxes I
couldn't believe it you know and um I
think because I'm in a in a in a haze a
lot of the times because of my spinal
cord injury I um I was like wow they
really went up and so it's a precious
thing the resources that are available
in this in this state and every dime
counts representative one question I
have is I know there's a lot of small
churches mine included where we are just
barely staying afloat yeah and we we
help Community we get calls from people
who need help and we help to the extent
we can help attacks attacks on on my
church and smaller churches pretty much
completely puts us out of the business
of helping people that's how tight we
are and I know a lot of other churches
are that tight so I guess what would be
your comment on on that scenario because
there are a lot of small churches who
are are and my church um I think that a
lot of churches are not have not even
begun to rebuild since covid and uh my
church St Philips in Asha is one of
those two and so this is a tough ask
this I know that well I know that this
is going to come out of this committee
itl I mean I I know when you have the
discussion you're going to say she's a
fruit cake W nuts her heart's in the
right position but it's not going to fly
but I am I am am cognizant of that and I
know that my church too that I
love there's just not the people there
like they should be and so yes I'm
cognizant of that thank you any other
questions on new topics uh not new
topics but new questions yes
representative Al
just yes ma'am uh just real quickly
um you were talking about separation of
church and state which doesn't exist in
the con Constitution what the
Constitution states is that the state
shall not interfere with
religion and considering John Marshall's
famous quote the power to tax is the
power to destroy and mccullock versus
Maryland how is this not
unconstitutional well representative auy
I um I I understand your position and
what I have is
um I think for
every um Court decision that you bring
up I can bring up one as well so
sorry Roger Williams founder of Rhode
Island was the first public official to
use this metaphor he opened that an
authentic Christian Church should would
be possible only if there was the wall
or a hedge of separation between the
wildness of the world and the garden of
the church the most famous use of the
metaphor was by Thomas
Jefferson um who said there should be a
wall of separation between church and
state there is
um I just want with citizens
united um did a disservice I believe
some people did think that it was a
lovely thing but I don't think it was a
lovely thing at all because it opened a
can of worms or even if I use another
metaphor uh Pandora's Box and how we
have access to to us to the policy
makers that's what my question is and
and how we are going to how we're going
to use
it just okay one quick follow up one
quick followup and just uh let everyone
know we have three more speakers on this
topic thank you you're aware that when
Roger Williams wrote his comment he was
talking about the state interfering with
the operation of a separate church
because he had escaped from a um
established religion in
Massachusetts and when Thomas Jefferson
was writing about the danburry
Connecticut he was defending the right
of the danburry Connecticut Baptist
Church to be an established church and
not have the state interfere with its
existence not merging the states
together you're aware of that correct
yes but it those things in my humble
opinion and it is a humble opinion is
that that should go both
ways that um the churches shouldn't be
meddling in the
government's stuff it's just just you
know you stay in your church you pray
and you do what you do you do you and
the government will do the government
and just because some people can raise a
lot of money on the internet to in in
influence policy to the detriment of the
access of the other people it just it
doesn't work for me in my heart and
that's why I wanted to start to have
this discussion because I'm hopeful that
that we can reach out to one another on
a policy level and have good
discussions and I I just want to say one
more thing clearly this is not a dig or
disrespect at any church or their work
that they do which I say is
marvelous thank
you all right thank you for your
testimony
all right next up we have representative
Ellen
Reid thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee
um I am sorry I've been running in and
out I have five bills just this morning
to to testify on and one of them kind of
the one I'm kind of bouncing back and
forth with you all on kind of intersects
with this um so for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent uh New Market
and new fields and for this discussion I
would also like to say I adjunct taught
um American government for 4 years so I
feel like I have a little bit of um a
little bit of a knowledge base on this
issue I wanted to address three things
that I heard come up I didn't hear the
entire discussion I apologize if I am
repeating so there was a question about
asking the prime sponsor so you feel
that we should tax religious schools but
not tax Public Schools I was very
confused by that because of course we
don't tax tax public institutions
they're paid for by taxes that seemed
kind of an odd concept um public means
the things that we are publicly funding
with taxes I think the better analogy is
we tax private for profit schools and
should we also tax religious schools so
I wanted to just address that question
also the concept of separation of church
and state and how um formative it was
for our Founders came up so generally
speaking it is considered to exist in
our constitution in the form of the
First Amendment both The Establishment
Clause and the free exercise clause
which I will speak to later in more
depth but the prime sponsor said that it
was her humble opinion that it should go
both ways and in fact it's not only her
humble opinion it was the opinion of the
framers of the Constitution because we
have both The Establishment Clause that
says the government will not um pass a
law regarding religion and the free
exercise clause saying that people are
allowed to practice their religion
freely um it already goes both ways and
so that's usually what we consider to be
the separation of church and state in
the
Constitution but it was also spoken
extensively by the writers of the uh
Federalist essays so the the concept and
these are the framers of our
constitution who hit the ground running
trying to convince the states of this
brand new nation to ratify our
Constitution and they spoke to this and
the reason that they they spoke to this
um was because it was out of a sense of
hey vote ratify this constitution
because this
separation um and this is to be fair
this was before the first amendment
actually the Bill of Rights was passed
but this separation this concept this
value that we hold will protect you
because it's never and this is why the
the bill I'm doing on free speech and
education right now that I'm bouncing
back and forth it is pertinent it's also
in that first amendment because it's
never the popular opinions that need
protecting it's the minority opinions
it's the unpopular opinions that need
protecting from the majority so that is
separation so I have a a question and I
I think it might sound factious but I
don't mean it in a factious way and it
does actually um ping off of something
that another representative said you
know which churches can can someone and
I mean this seriously and I know you
can't answer me right now but can
someone give me a definition of the
difference between say a predatory cult
and a religion because right now we have
religions that are tax exempt that are
based on science fiction writers saying
that there's an alien species of
microorganism in our blood we have
religions tax exempt religions based on
flying spaghetti monsters that one is
tongue and cheek obviously but there you
can come up with what is to prevent
someone from coming up with any set of
ridiculous
Notions and then getting tax exempt
status while they roll in the the
donations and I mean that very seriously
how do we legislate that how do we
legislate a genuine faith and we can't
because we can't make a law concerning
religion because of the the The
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment so this particular cacr does
not infringe on the first amendment in
fact it it's quite the opposite because
we're saying that even people without
faith deserve the protections of the
First Amendment so while you don't tax
churches currently you would tax a
organization and then I think of the
primary work of most religious
institutions most religious instit
institutions I think and I can speak
predominantly from um the Christian
faith I have a minor in religious
studies and Once Upon a Time pursued the
path of ordination but that was a long
time ago um and for the Christian faith
it is often cited that the work of the
church is to be the hands of and feet of
Christ in the world and so the church
and other religious organizations do a
lot of good work in the world and I
think that is predominantly the basis of
the idea that we should um give them tax
exempt status but like any other private
institution if you do charity in the
world that the money that goes to that
is actually tax exempt so why are we tax
exempting the entire organization when
we only need to exempt the charitable
work and I think that's an actual real
function that that could be used to say
to make the difference between say a
ridiculous kind of cult in an actual
faith-based organization that's doing
good work is if you tax exempt the
actual work you are thereby um
rewarding organizations that do good
work in in the community and you are
kind of penalizing through regular taxes
organizations that are not doing that
work but instead just using it to make
profit for
themselves
um and for what it's worth I think we
could use some Revenue but
having said all that I'm happy to try to
answer questions I'm not a co-sponsor on
this bill I just happen to be in the
right place in the right time and and
feel strongly about the
issue thank you for your testimony uh
any
questions yes representative fellows um
given your uh experience and background
with this I wonder if you can tell us
how what the churches were like at the
time that the constitution was was
signed much much smaller with the
exception of the Catholic Church of
course right what and what did they
do um I would imagine and I'm I wouldn't
call myself a historian by any stretch
but I would imagine they did a lot of
the same charitable work but what they
don't what they didn't do and I I grew
up in the South where we had mega
churches okay and we're talking about
multi- hundreds of acres for a
particular property and they would
fundraise and to put in their fifth
elevator and make the building bigger
and all and to do more marketing to to
get more donations and a lot of the
money that went into the church went
into that cycle of getting more money
and the pastors of these churches made
easily in the six figures and usually in
the seven figures so um that's what
didn't happen for the most part again
the Catholic church has a is a much
longer history and was much larger
organization but um the uh that the
Puritans for example as unpopular as
they were and as harsh as as they may
have been did not have that kind of
today okay thank
easy okay next I have and I don't can't
quite read this but representative
Robert
warry if I'm pronouncing that
correctly and uh actually let me just
say uh representative
um
saus did I pronounce that correctly um
if you could fill out a pink card at
some point
please okay yes all right thank you Mr
chair and honorable members uh I did not
intend to speak but um when my colleague
from NASA spoke I I felt compelled to
just step up here for a few minutes and
uh address some of the points um first
of all I'm horrified that she would ever
receive treatment
from uh poor treatment and abusive
treatment from churches
um there's a saying that there are both
Believers and makeb Believers and those
makeb Believers are wol wolves and
sheep's clothing and I would you know
suggest that perhaps those are the type
of people who attacked her because that
that is certainly not what uh Christian
churches should be doing and I'm
appalled at such
behavior
um
the concept of the separation of church
and state has already been stated and
and
um discussed I just want to reiterate
what my colleague from Hudson also said
is that the Constitution prohibits the
government overreach and prevents a
union between church and
state um and and it does it's not a
two-way door in fact um just to pull up
um significantly just I'm reading from a
a passage I or website I looked up real
quickly significantly numerous founding
fathers in early statements asserted
that religious Faith was the most
important source of civil virtues this
includes John Hancock John Adams
Benjamin Rush Thomas Jefferson uh
Charles Carroll Catholic from Maryland
of course John Witherspoon uh as well as
Constitution signers George Washington
Benjamin Franklin um Abraham Baldwin and
Statesmen such as Noah Webster John
Quincy Adams and our own Daniel Webster
so I can get uh references if anyone
should want those um I also want to
address that that aspect of
um that churches and Moss and synagogues
um all of which are in nashille I I
myself though representing Hudson I go
to a church in n Joshua um New Hampshire
is the most unchurched state in the US
clearly there is not a huge political
power being exerted in this state by the
churches moss and
synagogues um some of us might wish that
were that that were so because of the
Civil virtues that I mentioned before
but that is not uh the case I
believe uh last ly um the
churches are funded by people who are
already taxed and though they get a
benefit of uh deductions from their
charitable
contributions um that is a burden that
they
bear and those people who are not
donating to the church the Pressed uh
portion that my colleague from NASA
mentioned um those people receive the
community benefit of those relig
religious organizations but without the
burden of making those
donations so I I find this uh proposal
uh something that I could not uh support
and I just uh felt compelled to make
these few comments thank you for your
time thank you representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for your testimony I
was struck by your last comment about uh
people in the community getting the
benefits of the churches in their
community and I would like you to
expound on them because I'm not sure
what you're referring to so I can't
speak for every uh religious
organization but I know for my the own
church that I go to we uh reach out in
ministries to the community within NASA
and the greater NASA area we support uh
homeless Ministries we have a celebrate
recovery program for those who are
dealing with addictions we have other
similar types of Ministries that really
benefit the Greater Community as a whole
and are not intended to be solely
directed toward the members of our
church followup Mr chairman followup yes
follow up thank you I have done some
research I am also a representative from
NASA and I've done some research in
terms of some of the charitable
organizations the homeless services and
other kinds of services and I know that
some of those organiz ations in addition
to providing the services also uh expect
a fair amount of religious observance
among the people that they're helping
and how does that square with your
comment that the churches should not
be uh forced to pay taxes whe because
they're doing charitable work when part
of the charitable work requires the
recipients to be getting
proed so so that was not my argument and
and so um my argument was that the
people who are not being who are not
contributing who are not donating to the
churches still receive a community
benefit
and as far as um the
prizing I I can't speak for that I I
suppose in um the Southern New Hampshire
rescue center might do that I I really
don't don't know um but I know at the
homeless Ministry that my particular
church is involved in there's there's a
a brief message but it is not you must
come to church it is not you know
forcing the these people to do anything
and a matter of fact there are people
who actually after receiving their food
or or materials that will help them get
through the times that they're suffering
um just walk away and they don't they
don't receive that so it's not it's not
by compulsion we certainly don't have
armed guards forcing people to listen um
so if I would not say that it's fully
compulsory I think it uh to some degree
it uh there's certainly an incentive
because they're receiving materials but
um but I think that's uh not is not
mandatory
yes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair uh thank you representative for
taking my question so I I understand
where the other Representatives coming
from in terms of you know her question
my question to you is is it prizz or is
it teaching a man or a woman to fish so
that you don't have to feed him every
day my experience with Grace Capitol
because I helped with that project is
they asked people to be there so they
could train them to fend for themselves
if you will or to help themselves lift
themselves out of poverty would you
agree
disagree can you
clarify thank you I would agree because
I think to to to some degree I
think a great portion of what people
suffer in the world is tied up in their
identity of themselves and the one thing
that uh faith and I think particularly
the Christian faith can raise up the
identity of the individuals
and cause them to know that they are
loved and accepted regardless of their
conditions that their worth is not based
on their contributions to society
necessarily but is based on an
overwhelming love from God and not
from um their current status so can it
change the mindset of those to whom
these churches Minister
absolutely can that mindset then help
these people to rise up above their
circumstances
absolutely
no thank
you okay seeing no more thank you for
your
testimony all right we have uh two more
tibo thank you Mr chair members of the
committee let me pull up my statement um
so before I begin with my written
testimony I would like to point out that
I'm my name is James TBO I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire
legislative youth advisory Council which
is a statutory Committee of the New
Hampshire State Legislature under RSA
19k and I would point out that that we
have
um Catholic members myself included
Protestant members atheist members um
diverse oh absolutely I
apologize yeah I understand um but um so
I would just say that we have a hold on
one second represent what Advisory Board
the New Hampshire legislative youth
advisory Council RSA 19k um I would
point out that we have um a wide variety
of religious diversity on our Council
and we all unanimously agreed to
recommend this bill in expedient to or
this um resolution inexpedient to
legislate and that was
because we believe that religious um
organizations provide a a lot of good
for their communities um religious
expression is one of the most
fundamental rights of our state and
Nation being protected not only by the
First Amendment to the Constitution of
the United States but also part one
Article 5 of The Constitution of the
State of New Hampshire religious
organizations engage in a substantial
amount of charitable good for our state
from hospitals to schools to feeding and
clothing people in their time of need
and they can only do this because they
are exempt from taxes and can instead
put that money to good use um this
amendment would strip religious
organizations of that tax exempt status
meaning less income to keep the lights
on let alone help the people they strive
to assist in a on in a Time where Church
attendance is already floundering um
churches rely on donations in order to
continue offering clerical Services as
well as charitable ones and religious
Charities tend to be some of the best
funded because um um religious people
regardless of social status have been
found to be 25% more likely to donate to
charity and poor religious people are
actually far more likely to donate to
charity than even rich or middle class
um religious people these people
typically um donate to their churches or
organizations in some way affiliated
with their churches because they're
expecting that they're going to be able
to help as many people as possible with
that tithing but that impact would be
lessened if those donations were taxed
cacr 18 also creates a clear
hypocritical and in our view potentially
unconstitutional double standard between
religious and secular Charities um both
can be sources for incredible good yet
one would be penalized simply for um um
simply because they worship God how is
that acceptable in a nation that was
founded on the idea that we are endowed
by our creator with certain unalienable
rights and that we as an American people
have a quote firm Reliance on Divine
Providence we believe that it isn't
religious organizations would still
retain tax exempt status at a federal
level um which also shows an anom
anomalous disparity that further calls
this amendment into question if the
federal government recognizes the need
for a tax exemption on religious
organizations why not the state of New
Hampshire if it could um further be
asked if the government would even be
the most effective party using those
funds it is often found that private
Charities including churches and
religious organizations use their money
far more responsibly in order to stretch
each dollar as much as possible um these
Charities are actually Limited in how
much they are given and would be further
limited should this amendment pass this
is in stark contrast with government
which can simply raise taxes and take
the people's money at threat of
prosecution or go into debt should it
want to fund some new welfare scheme or
there loaded ineffective program that
would be slower and less responsive to
the needs of the poor than a private
charity would be Unbound by Pages upon
pages of Statute in the interest of
protecting fundamental constitutional
rights to freedom of religious
expression ensuring that churches and
religious groups can maintain their
charitable excellence and allowing for
each dollar tithe to a church from
congregants young and old alike um to
actually go where it's intended rather
than into the government's coffers the
um the New Hampshire legislative youth
advisory Council pursuing to RSA 19 K3
paragraph 1 strongly recommends cacr 18
be voted inexpedient to legislate and
would further encourage a motion of
indefinite postponement once it reaches
the house floor thank you and I'd be
questions representative PL yes th this
is a clerk question thank you for the
testimony could you provide that please
form I emailed it to the committee you
did okay I did yes and I would point out
that I'm an 18-year-old and that I'm in
high school I I for that I I skipped
school today to be here because I cared
this much about
um I I'd appreciate no because I was at
the state house twice last week as well
and I'll be here again on Thursday so
please don't call truy let's um I'll
take your question in a minute let's
just keep in mind I have one more
speaker after this um and um we will
have a work session on this um so uh and
let's keep any questions to
something uh new in that has been asked
yes yes I i' just like to say that the
um youth advisory Council I've I've
interacted with some of the other
members and and I'm
extraordinarily impressed with the
caliber of those students and their
thoughtfulness so and I so I just want
to clarify that that they vote the
council unanimously voted okay y thank
thank you absolutely because we were we
have a lot of IDE ological diversity on
the council but we all agreed that
religious organizations provide a
substantial good for our community and
for our state and so we could not see
any way in which this would not only be
allowed but even more realistically
speaking that would even pass with the
two-thirds required in the Senate um so
that was generally um our our largest
concerns okay seeing no more questions
thank you for for me oh mine is hard
okay I just wanted to make a comment
thank you for representing your group
absolutely um I think your input was
very valuable I appreciate it thank
you thank you now seeing no more
questions thank you for your testimony
absolutely thank you so much for
having I have a point of order sure I
missed this um at what point do we do a
blue sheet after we've done a hearing on
one bill or do all the blue sheets at
the end of the session I don't think
we've been clear we can
um we can get a list of whatever you
likees they're usually supposed to be a
summary of what the blue sheet yeah we
will when this testimony is over we'll
sheet okay um one more speaker uh
Meredith
cook
microphone there we go good morning my
name is Meredith cook I'm the chancellor
of the Roman Catholic dicese of
Manchester on behalf of Bishop Peter
labashi I am here to support oppose uh
cacr 18 we believe that the Catholic
church is the largest non-governmental
provider of charitable assistance in New
Hampshire and do want to make clear I
know I'm going I'm not going to repeat
anything that's been stated earlier
today I have crossed off a lot of my
testimony to move you along here today
um but do want to make clear that the
proposed con uh constitutional amendment
is Broad and would remove the exemptions
for not just churches but also all
religious organizations just in case
that was not clear in the testimony
already presented to you today um so as
the largest uh non-governmental provider
of charitable assistance in New
Hampshire that we believe we are our
parishes offer a wide range of
assistance here in New Hampshire so that
includes fin financial assistance fuel
assistance clothing assistance uh other
basic necessities utilities um anything
that folks in uh the community may need
um we also Catholic Charities maintains
offices around the states to work with
folks to reduce poverty Catholic
Charities operates the New Hampshire
Food Bank uh Liberty house to hope uh
help struggling veterans homeless
veterans in the community um and also to
support um those who are struggling who
are recent immigrants uh those who need
assistance with legal assistance uh
immigrants who need assistance with
legal assistance um Catholic Hospitals
also provide an amazing amount of
charitable care as
well the Catholic church is also active
in advocating for all those folks that I
just described so we've talked today a
little bit about the advocacy positions
of the Catholic church but to be clear
if you have not seen outside this
committee the Catholic church is here in
the State House on a regular basis
talking and advocating for all of those
people I just described immigrants
refugees the ill the elderly all of
those folks as well and I can only speak
to you today on behalf of the Catholic
church and those contributions but we
are not alone houses of worship in New
Hampshire provide
indispensable
contributions for the elderly the ill
the poor the
vulnerable we've already talked a little
bit it was disc today but if those if
that think about in your own communities
if that floor if that backbone of your
community was gone that Gap that state
and local governments would have to make
up would be grave and would need to be
made up in those areas where state and
local governments have an obligation to
do that thinking only of Catholic
Charities and the six nursing homes that
that Catholic Charities provides and the
obligation that the government has to
provide and Medicaid support that that's
provided I do want to address some of
the issues that were raised by the
sponsor and the public policy issues
that are
discussed and I will not hide from that
does the Catholic Church oppose abortion
absolutely does the Catholic Church have
a position of uplifting and upholding
the Dignity of every human person
absolutely should representative sophus
have been subject to attacks absolutely
not because every single person as an
human and an innate dignity and respect
and that should not have happened to her
um at the same time as I've mentioned
this the Catholic Church will be here
and will be here advocating for the
Dignity of every human person from the
beginning of Life to the end of life and
everything in the middle from lifting up
every person who is experiencing poverty
and every person in between and has the
right to do
so and we will be here and we will do
that but the point that I bring up at
the beginning that this also has an
impact on other religious organizations
this bill has a disparate impact because
it does not come down upon other
nonprofit organizations so religious
organizations who hold these beliefs and
hold these positions will be subject to
taxation but other nonprofit
organizations who come before this body
and hold the same positions who come
here with the same speech would not be
subject to taxation so the only
difference is where you worship ship and
the religious beliefs that you have
would subject you to Taxation and that's
do and to give you some examples so
while St Joseph Hospital in NASA would
be subject to taxation Southern New
Hampshire Medical Center would
not and while St ano college would be
subject to taxation Southern New
Hampshire University would not and so
for these reasons I do agree with the
sponsor I think this is a tremendous
opportunity for discussion for
opportunity to get to know each other to
understand the positions that we take
and to have begin that dialogue but I do
urge you to oppose cacr
18 thank you thank you representative PL
yes when I was watching you you were ad
living a lot but I also saw paper in
front of did you have written testimony
do you have written testimony to submit
to you today I did not submit it
electronically I will get that to you
today thank you thank you uh yes
representa thank you Mr chair and this
question is probably better addressed in
a work session but I was a member of a
board of a small
nonprofit that um was surviving doing
okay and it has recently on the last
couple of years its operation has been
Charities this this was not a religious
organization to begin with but now that
it's under the uh board directive of the
Catholic Charities would that
nonprofit now also be subjected to uh
property taxes when where community that
it's uh are are are Exempted from the
this proposal
um have to pay property taxes now that
it's part of Catholic Charities yes if
it were if this if this proposal went
forward um the difference from one
governance structure to the next uh from
one uh from one day to the next would be
that under previously it would not be
subject to taxation but under Catholic
Charities it would be subject to
you yes representative ORS thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so in the last couple years with fuel
oil prices and energy prices is soaring
have you had more requests for help the
same or less fuel uh fuel requests have
increased that's correct do you have any
idea how much uh that I do not have if
you would be interested I could obtain
that information and how many classes do
these people have to take in order to
get fuel assistance from the Catholic
church so from I would have to obtain
that information from you for fuel
assistance in our parishes that would
vary um the parishes on a parish level
um the parishes have discretion to
determine how they would um distribute
that um on the Catholic CH from Catholic
Charities for assistance for the for um
the for cath the Catholic Charities
model really is about lifting people out
of poverty and there are requirements
for going through um classes in
education to receive assistance are are
these religious classes or educational
followup please are these religious
classes or are they educational for to
lift them out of pover from Catholic
Charities they are not religious classes
they are they are classes to lift people
you okay thank you very
much all right this uh is there anyone
else who has not signed a pink card that
wants to testify on
this okay seeing none I will just uh
mention on the blue sheet that we have
one person for this uh Bill and um seven
against okay I'm going to close the uh
18 okay um I apologize we're a little
bit behind
back
okay all right I'm going to open the uh
1191 right now I have four speakers on
um
all right I have a I have a couple that
okay um okay please announce your
good morning Mr chair and fellow
colleagues um Representative Bob hey
from aramac and I come here today to
introduce bipartison House Bill
1191 with regard to an exemption to the
meals and rooms tax for the meals on
meals dout restaurant
program this program was started about a
ago
this program was started about a year
and a half ago and has been very well
received by the seniors that have signed
up for this
program the program is born of the meals
on Wheel senior meal delivery program
that allows seniors a chance to get out
and have a CH choice of a healthy
nutritionally designed meal and also
allows them to socialize and interact
with other seniors as well as restaurant
guests and
employees this program has brought it
people together after a time when
loneliness and isolation had skyrocketed
it allows seniors rather than just
getting meals delivered to them the
opportunity to get out of what is many
times an empty home with a delivery
person may be the only person they see
and interact with during a
day to me and many of the sponsors it
makes no sense to Grant State funds to a
group or organization and then tax that
group when they use those
funds when we ran into the Governor at
event he told him about the issue and he
said get the bill to my desk and I will
sign
it this bill has both Republican and
Democrats that have signed on in support
as well as members from both
Chambers the president of Meals on
Wheels Mr John Erico is also here to
testify to answer questions on anything
you may
questions representative PL that's a
disclosure I have one of those cards in
awesome okay thank you for oh I'm sorry
representative SPS yeah thank you for
taking my question I'm not familiar with
the program but I'm
wondering as the program exists now does
the restaurant operator or any other
private Enterprise have the ability to
take a tax exemption for Their
donation I do not believe so but he can
you
and I'm sorry yes why don't you
approach John
Enrique
hello Mr chairman representatives of the
committee thank you for allowing me to
speak on this important bill my name is
John Eric quzo I'm the president and CEO
of Meals on Wheels of Hillsboro County
uh we operate under the older Americans
Act and the older Americans act one of
the mandates is that we help reduce
social isolation and
loneliness and uh and over the past 50
years the way this has been
traditionally done is through something
called Community dining and Community
dining Across the Nation some sometimes
looks like serving a meal at a senior
center to a group of older adults so
that they can
socialize and for the better part of 40
years this has been a very successful
and positive model it's had an impact on
on many many older adults throughout the
country however over the past 10 years
on a national level and a local level
we've noticed that participation in
traditional Community diet in has been
on the decline about 10% declined uh a
year over the past 10 years there's been
lots of studies as to why this this has
occurred and some of the main reasons
are uh stigma of going to a senior
center uh being told when you have to
eat and not having a choice of food and
so after doing some uh rigorous research
uh we found that we could although it's
never been done in New Hampshire before
contract with a restaurant a local
restaurant to serve those very same
meals that our dietician
approves uh and uh and that we
anticipate that
participation uh would increase in
community
dieting and we started a pilot funded by
the Meals on Wheels America group
through a grant pilot was successful we
worked with State of New Hampshire come
up with some some guidelines on this
that was successful and now we're in
Three restaurants in Hillsboro County
and it's been a huge success
participation has been
extraordinary and the stories that we
hear about the impact on people uh has
been
wonderful now here's the the
catch the restaurants we pay the
restaurants using funding that uh is in
part provid provided by the older
Americans act federal government the
state and we have to fund raise for the
balance we pay that to the restaurant
the restaurant has to pay meals tax on
that for each meal that equates to be
about a buck a buck a meal and if we're
if we're producing let's say 30,000
meals uh a year on this program that's
$30,000 that is being taken out of the
program and being sent back to the
federal government or to the state
government uh in terms of ta meals tax
uh so what this bill proposes is that uh
anybody restaurant who's participating
under this program is approved by uh the
the Bureau of elderly Adult Services
could be exempt from paying that tax
thereby allowing us to reinvest that
money into back into the program so just
to give you an example if we're paying a
restaurant today $13 a meal uh once this
bill passes we will only have to pay
them $12 a meal that extra dollar will
go back into the program to serve more
meals that's my
testimony thank you any questions yes
representative
shamberg going back to representative
spilsbury's
question could you answer his question
about
do they get a tax did you ask a
tax representative spillsbury was it a
tax what
right um if I may ask the question again
and I use the word exemption I really
meant deduction um it's th this on the
surface seems like a good idea to me I'm
just trying to understand whether there
are any other reciprocal um implications
to it is there a tax deduction currently
taken by the restaurant or any other
entity no thank you for the question
this is a very unique situation where we
as a nonprofit are paying a for-profit
restaurant for every meal they serve
under this program so no there is no
there is no other way to do
it it's taxing State funding which is
counterproductive representative
fellows um thank you I I'm not clear as
to whether or not you're represent like
the Meals on Wheels program for the
whole state or just for your county but
e either way can you tell me anything
about the number of meals overall and
how many are being prepared by like
staff at the senior
centers versus coming from the
restaurants yep and and also it sound
like you were saying are people going to
the restaurants to get get the food yeah
is that wonderful so so why don't they
go to the senior center they don't want
to so there's been a steady decline in
participation on a national and local
level in traditional Community dining so
just to give you um just to give you a a
a snapshot to put in reference in our
best year under Community dining
traditional Community dining we served
12,000 meals on our best
year Hillsboro County yeah but but these
numbers are similar through through
State and National for Hillsboro County
12,000 uh we introduced this this dinal
club program and we're looking to exceed
30,000 meals just for the dout club
meaning that it's been much more popular
people are participating and yet yes
they go to a restaurant they get a card
and this card has uh a QR code on it and
they present it and they get a separate
meal and that meal is a separate menu
I'm sorry and that menu is approved by
our dietician this is what the dout club
card looks like and it comes with eight
meals a month
preloaded so you can get eight meals a
month at a local one of those three
local
restaurants uh the meal is nutritious
meets all the daily requirements put
forth as required by the older Americans
Act and the biggest thing is people are
socializing uh loneliness is killing
people and and this is a a pandemic of
loneliness the the Surgeon General of
the United States last may put out an
advisory uh issuing an epidemic mic of
loneliness in the United States just
this last May uh you are 50 times higher
likely to get Alzheimer's or other
serious medical conditions as a result
of isolation and loneliness this is
something that is helping people in real
time uh if we could get more funding for
this program we could expand the program
we'd like to go into some of the more
rural towns uh right now we're in
Manchester we're in uh Pinardville uh
and we are in marac uh we have plans to
have one in nashwa and we'd like to go
out towards the Peterboro area uh and
other Meals on Wheels providers have
taken an interest in the state now that
we've test piloted in doing this program
I know there's High
Aly thank you um the way it had been
described to me was that the restaurant
agreed to provide a meal to the people
who would show up on a particular day of
the week uh in which case they're
socializing but if I show up or
representative PL shows up with his card
and um just sits at a table by himself
and eats his
meal um is that
socializing showing up is 99% of the job
you're not you're getting more
interaction doing that that than being
in your living room alone I I'll give
you a story there was a a gentleman who
was in his 90s who was from nashwa and
he felt guilty about using the card he
says well you know I feel guilty because
I have money I said well if you have
money you should donate and he does uh
but he go I said what would you be doing
if you weren't out here he goes I'd be
sitting home alone and he came for the
first time alone and it was
wonderful fast forward six months later
he knows everybody there they had his
birthday party there everybody
celebrated them he has more people in
his life now because he did that one
trip to that
restaurant people are pulling tables
together socializing now when you go to
some of these restaurants it's Mor it's
it's wonderful I encourage anybody uh to
go to there and and experience that for
yourself I think you're all qualified by
the way for the cars representative
PL this is uh because my name was
mentioned I I've used it a few times not
as often as some of my fellows uh sister
uh residents to in my over 55 community
but when I do go out it's six of
us thank you uh representative fellows
um yes so the ply the senior center in
Plymouth has congregate meals and
anybody can go and you're not you're not
required to pay for it they don't ask
you anything about your income and um a
lot of people do make donations though
because there are people they feel you
know they could they can they can afford
the food but they want to go to the
center and before covid they you know
wanted to get together with other people
so I have two parts of the question I I
didn't hear an answer to what you your
response about did they have to go on a
certain time in day or could they just
go wherever they wanted whenever they
wanted to the restaurant and they could
take other people with them they could
take their grandkids whatever or um
and or and also is there an income limit
on who gets the card thank you for the
question let me start with the income
limit this is the the the congregate d
program uh the same congregate dining
program as you'd see in a senior center
there's no income requirement as and
that's how it was designed through the
older Americans act so we don't ask what
your income is uh and uh the we don't
ask for money we suggest a donation of
$4 a meal we have a donation box at each
restaurant where people can drop in a
few
bucks about half the people
donate which is
fine uh as far as when you can go that's
up to the restaurants uh right now most
of the restaurants you can go pretty
much anytime some of them will say well
you can only go between you know uh when
we open at 11:30 till 5:30 great you
know uh but our experience is is that
most times people they'll accept the
card does that answer your
question
any other questions representative Aly
yeah I think well maybe Grafton county
is especially struggling with this
because we have a really strong Senior
Center on uh group around the entire
County uh
but you saying you're saying that you
are not getting that kind of
participation in any other county in the
state no I'm saying how many how big is
this program going to get and who pays
for it sure I'm saying that it is a
national
phenomenon that we've experienced as
well in the state I mean we we have five
Meals on Wheels of Hillsboro County has
five traditional congregate dining
centers uh throughout Hillsboro County
that you know you might get a dozen
people 12 people 15 people but we also
have other community dining experiences
that are less traditional uh and and so
we need to attract more
people so I would say that what you're
seeing right now today in 10 years you
won't see it you'll see a big reduction
because that's the
question representative fellows um yes
just for additional information so the
traditional Meals on Wheels where where
a meal is delivered to somebody's home
are these coming from restaurants or or
how are those being prepared well let
representative Aly I wanted to say there
was a a question an additional part of
your question that I didn't answer which
is how big will it get um and who's
funding it uh we get
approximately 2third of our funding from
the federal government in the State and
the other third we have to raise which
is over a million dollars a year uh how
big can it get it it'll get as big as
people are willing to donate and state
and the federal government are willing
to
fund uh so Meals on Wheels traditional
Meals on Wheels is most of our business
uh in comparison to community dining or
congregate dining or the D out club uh
those are all about this big meals on
wheels traditional Meals on Wheels
delivering at home is about this big
it's it's a major part of what we do um
that's going strong uh we continue and I
think from meeting with the other Meals
on Wheels providers just on uh Monday I
can tell you that they've all said that
strong yes so my question was the ones
that are that go out delivered by car to
the people are those coming from
prepared by restaurants or if not how
are those prepared not that I know of
for me it's it's coming from a
caterer some a caterer in other words
somebody uh produces the meals Mass
produces the meals because we have to we
have to deliver uh about 7,000 meals
every week uh there are some Meals on
Wheels providers we use
restaurants uh on a limited basis to
deliver some meals to community dining
sites there are some Meals on Wheels
providers that cook their own
food um I'm not aware of any that use
restaurants however to do their hom
delivered
meals does that answer your
question okay representative ORS thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question so I you probably said it and I
missed it how old do you have to be to
get the card 60 okay and does followup
and does that qualify to uh for us to
run for US
Senate good question thank
you any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much thank
you all right I have two cards left uh
both from Dr um I don't know if one of
you prefers to speak first or not but I
have Lauren ulvan and
Wendy um mefier if I'm saying that
correct
welcome please introduce yourselves good
morning Mr chair my name is uh and
members of the committee my name is Keen
tax policy Council new H Department of
Revenue good morning my name is Lauren O
Sullivan I'm the senior Financial
Analyst at the Department of
Revenue you know I I apologize I think I
skipped a card um I don't know if you
guys want to testify last
or you want to testify now it probably
doesn't matter um I I think it it
doesn't matter too much uh especially
yeah the we do not have a position on
this bill we're here to just provide
information and answer any questions as
it pertains to administering the tax
proposal
okay please oh you want to answer
question okay representative shamber
will you continue to speak I'm sorry no
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh will these um
uh uh restaurants be audited every year
program um representative that's a very
good question currently uh because this
is a a
new well the the voucher program we
currently do not have an audit program
specifically um geared just for the for
the voucher program not that I'm aware
of
now I I have a question is would this be
a is this a difficulty for Dr
to um I mean in G does it affect your
software or your ability
to to figure out whether the right
amount of tax is being put in where some
taxed I believe that the um for the
administration of this tax we need to
have the information uh when the The
Operators submit their um M and M&R
return to the Dr uh we'll probably have
to um redesign the form to accommodate
that um that capability to allow the uh
M&R operator to report such information
um and um I I believe that is to the
extent that uh that any kind of
challenge uh would would be you know I
don't expect it to go any further than
that the other thing that we might have
a concern was um when we were discussing
this was whether what uh the patrons who
take advantage of this program um if
they were to
be um I guess if they they were to
purchase meals that were specifically
within the program and and meals that
were outside the program and how is that
going to be um managed because only the
meals that would be uh within the
program would be exempt whereas the
meals that is not uh will not be exempt
and then uh will the operator be able to
bifurcate their billing process and
therefore report it uh correctly to the
Dr okay so if I'm understanding you
correctly from a Dr perspective it's a
change to a form it shouldn't be that
costly for you to do that but on the
operator
side there's some question as to what
has to happen uh that is correct because
we're not familiar with how the
operators are currently managing that
process um and if they and if um if
there are such a situation I'm not sure
um I believe that um participants in
this uh in the voucher program from what
we've read through um through research
is that the the meals are very specific
and they're only out of a certain manual
or something like that and um but will
the patrons who come will they be able
to order out of this menu and all of
that menu I'm not really sure and then
how is that going to be how's that that
purchase going to be to to take take
effect okay John I'll call you up in a
minute we'll let Dr
finish um any other question yes
representative spilburg thank you Mr
chairman um Keen in your uh fiscal uh
note quick
guide the fourth paragraph says current
M&R tax law treats certain meals as not
taxable meals under RSA 78
a6c and includes an exception quote in
accordance with federal law meals
purchased with nutrition assistance
benefits issued pursuant to a program
that prohibits the assessment of aate
tax close quote so I want to make sure I
understand that is that
saying that under current M&R law there
already is a carveout that makes these
meals not subject to M&R or is the
exception that's being referred to there
an exception to the treatment as not
taxable what is that
saying so that specifically is referring
to let's say if the federal law itself
has some kind of provision that says
that okay this the meals that's provided
through this law shall be exempt from
state taxes then then that would apply
well and so does that lead to the last
sentence there the OAA does not appear
to have an explicit prohibition
therefore you're saying it is subject to
tax corre under current law and that's
why the bill the proponents want the
bill that is correct okay thank you okay
representative Aly did you have a
question I have question microphone
microphone are we going to hear from the
Department of Human S Health and Human
Services from from the section that
deals with this program
because um they're the only ones that
can give us information about where the
funding is coming
from well we can certainly have a work
session and do that I don't know if uh I
don't have a card from Health and Human
Services here today they're really hard
to get representative PL I want to make
a statement when I've gone for uh one of
these meals uh they run the card so
that's their proof when they submit a
bill to the state to get reimbursed so
the question there was questions about
auditing that is the proof that's the
audit they can't inflate the numbers to
try to avoid meals tax and any other
meal and just full disclosure I can
afford the meal so I pay to the state
the entire cost of the meal not
including the tip because I believe the
restaurant okay so um based on what
representative PL just said does that
imply that the state
already or or is the state KN doing
anything I'm I'm a little confused as to
who's if they're scanning this
card who's how's that working or is
that
I mean that that if they're scanning the
card the restaurant is not charging the
meals and rooms tax right
now okay well we we'll get back to we'll
get back to you in a minute then all
right uh representative fellows um yeah
I have a question about the N the
estimates that you made of number of
meals where did that come from because I
mean a lot of people at this in this
room like are hearing about this for the
first time and saying like oh maybe I
can go down and get a car you
know so those estimates came from Health
and Human Services we were not um given
information on the contract agencies and
the number of meals per year but they
they performed a similar analysis that
information okay any other questions
seeing none thank you very
John for the record John Eric quzo Meals
on Wheels
again so the card you present the card
it's often completely different menu you
get a separate menu you present the card
the menu each item has a number they
scan the card it tells the restaurant
your name and how many meals you're
qualified for and they put in the number
tells us which meal they had so we know
what you ate by the way um and then that
goes directly into the restaurant's
database they have it we have it it's
it's immediate billing and at every week
I get a summary from each restaurant of
how many people ate and here's how much
you owe me we compare that to our
database and then we pay it and then and
based off that billing we build the
state under congregate dining and that's
how that works so you have a triple
check for an audit you have the State
numbers our numbers and the restaurants
numbers so when you build a state you're
also billing the state for the rooms and
meals tax portion of that yeah we're
passing it on to the state because
that's what uh that's that's in the cost
of the meal it's built in just seems
ridiculous that we would have to do that
okay thank you that was a good
clarification does anyone else have
representative Aly yes uh from what
you're talking about popularity not
knowing anything about the other eight
counties on this could balloon out of
our budget if
we
um and I would really not like to pass
this bill without getting information
from the Health and Human Services
Division they didn't even bother to talk
to LBA they sent it to Dr to include and
it's just about the first two
places um
and on it is very difficult to get them
to this committee un to the dedicated
fund committee
uh and you have um an in with them
perhaps you could get them to be willing
to show up to talk to us about how much
of this is federal funding and how much
of it is local and is the federal
funding capped and all that kind of
thing we'll reach out to them
representative Aly um work session and
let me just reiterate this only goes
this only gets as big as the funding
will allow it and right now it's capped
and it will be capped before this bill's
passed it will be capped after this bill
is pass what is the cap right now we
well we we're under contract
specifically for uh Community dining for
59,000 units
25,000 units meaning meals 25,000 we
have set aside just for the ding out
club anything we do above that I I have
to fund raise 100% for that meal okay so
so it is capped at this time so it's not
like we really need to worry about it
doing out of
control I have under I'm under contract
with the state of New Hampshire for
Hillsboro County for
59,000 Community or congregate dining
meals a
year out of that
59,000 I have set aside
25,000 just for the din out club now I
can use those interchangeably as it
stands now we're going to far exceed
that but I'm staying within that
59,000 meals that we've been given every
year for the past I don't know how many
years so you're not actually asking for
an increase here you're just asking for
the fact that if the state would take
away the M&R tax it would give you the
ability to provide a few more meals
absolutely 100% okay yes representative
yeah I think
this I'll ask this as a question but
it's uh isn't it true kind of question
that I think follows on the point just
made by representative
janigian um isn't it true
that the risk to the state of loss of
tax dollars only relates to what you're
currently paying so that's what the Dr
has figured for us and you haven't seen
those numbers but going
forward if your program expands that's
great but what we're giving up is maybe
future additional revenues coming in if
the tax continue to apply but we don't
have those revenues right now we're not
giving up anything that we currently
have except what we've been receiving in
the past for these limited number of
meals that you're currently providing is
that correct yeah you wouldn't have had
these revenues if we hadn't develop this
program and now we're getting these
revenues a discrete amount but no we're
and we're going to give those up if we
pass this bill going forward but we're
not not giving up anything else we're
giving up the prospect of getting more
if you expand the program
but that's not giving up something we
have in hand what you're doing is you're
contributing to a program that is
keeping our older population healthy
engaged and out of nursing homes that's
doing thank you oh I'm sorry one more
question representative fellow I just I
had two questions is this a the money's
most of this money is Flowing down from
the federal government without that so
let me finish please you know so I'm
wondering is this a pilot program in
which case it might be terminated and
I'd also like to know like what other
restaurants in your
area this is um
approximately I'm going to get the
number slightly wrong but let's say it's
30% from the federal government 30% from
the state and the
other 40% I've got a fund raise for
that's where the money is coming down
and and maybe there's like 2%
participant
donations um the other question you had
was where are the
restaurants my my question was is this a
federal pilot program or is it is it
cemented right in statute that this is
going to continue and what were the
restaurants yeah it's in statute they
don't mention restaurant voucher but
we're what we're following to the tea is
what is required under the older
Americans act for congregate dining uh
whether you do it at a senior center or
a local restaurant as long as we follow
the rules we're following the rules it
was a pilot for the State of New
Hampshire uh which we have already
completed and now there are um uh
guidelines in place it's an accepted and
adopted program by The Bureau and um and
you want to know the restaurants there
is the white birch eery in Pinardville
which is also known as
gtown uh there is the um village eery in
Manchester three wonderful
them
representative ORS thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question so you
mentioned it would keep people out of
the nursing home
how isolation and loneliness has uh
gives will you there's a 50 times
greater chance that you'll develop
Alzheimer's or other serious illness as
a result isolation loneliness this has
by far been the most effective program
in the state to help reduce isolation
and loneliness for our older population
you okay thank you very much thank
you now the card um that I skipped over
was
bully
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Dick Boule from The
Firm of Denny and Boule and today I as I
have for over 25 years represented the
Statewide meals and wheels program and
I'm assisted by my associate uh Alis
kruis from uh our
firm and I just want you to understand
that this is an addition to what meals
and wheels has been providing Statewide
the conget meals and the hom delivered
meals and this is a great program that
John has come up with I want you to also
understand that it takes a lot of work
to set it up it's not something just
boom like other uh parts of the state
are trying to do the same thing but
they're learning from what John has
succeeded on and it's a lot of work to
it for example I brought a letter today
from the tri Tri County Community Action
of the nor country coart County Alex and
I will pass that out so you each can see
briefly
this is a letter from the director of
the Tri County
program uh in Berlin it says uh members
of the House Ways and Means Committee
please accept this correspondence from
the Tri County Community Action Program
senior meals and wheels of coat County
in support of House Bill
1191 the restaurant vulture program to
be exempt from rooms and meals tax the
success of the restaurant V program the
RVP bu meals and wheels Hillsboro County
offers choice in dining for local senior
residents to enjoy a delicious
nutritious meal with family and friends
and support local restaurants that's
very important some of these restaurants
really need this business and they're
really anxious to get this business that
they would not ordinarily have seniors
come out to our benef
benefits for area sting is in the
companionship and time spent enjoying a
meal together and possibly meeting a new
friend or two senior meals of Kart
county is currently working on
developing restaurant Partnerships in
the North country and by waving the
rooms and meals tax it would certainly
help support the financial viability of
the RVP in serving our most northern
senior residents thank you for your
consideration Angela Johnson director of
Tri Tri County now in another part of
the state that doesn't presently have
this res program rant program is
Rockingham County I know some of you
people are from that County I talk with
the director um Tim da the other day and
Tim is saying that he would too if this
bill passes he's going to try to expand
it into Rockingham County so people are
learning of what John has done in
Hillsboro that can be done throughout
the state but please bear in mind it's a
lot of work to set it up and because the
people right now that run these programs
get the handsful more and more people
are demanding a meal on WE to have a hom
delivered meal there's a need for it
believe me and so this is just adding to
what we already have we have 10 agencies
that do this in the state do you have
any questions GL to try to answer it or
certainly Mr kumis could help me thank
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you very
much um I do have a question of
Dr um I have a card for Lauren and for
Wendy is Wendy here or Keen will you in
for
Wendy okay can I just cross her name off
okay that's all I have for pink cards is
there anyone else would like to testify
on HB
1191 all right seeing none I'll close
all right I'd like to ask the committee
a
question um my preference would be to
continue I know we're we're past uh
where we want to be but my uh
inclination would be to excuse me
continue on is uh people in general okay
with that okay seeing a lot of positive
continue all right I'm going to open the
1254 I've got about uh 12 people who
wish to speak on 1254 so I would ask uh
that uh you keep your comments
concise and if you are later in the
process and you're saying something
that's already been said before I would
encourage you to skip that part of your
testimony um so with that
I will start with uh mayor Douglas
mcachran
chairperson sandborne members of the
committee my name is Delan mccan it's my
privilege to serve as the mayor of the
city of Portsmouth uh great to see Mr
chairman just a moment Mr chairman yes
uh do we normally go with the prime
sponsor not being able to present first
that's a good point happy to seed my
timee I'm sorry about that I should
start with the prime sponsor thank you
representative
shamberg we'll be right back to you Mr
Mayor and point of order does he
understand about the
chairman uh you are the chairman I'm I'm
the chairman representative Sanborn is
out representative
Jan thank you all right uh Prime sponsor
representative buo yes
sorry okay thank you Mr
chairman for the record my name is Tom
buo I represent Carol County District
number one the town of Conway and I'm
here to introduce House Bill 1254 and to
request that this committee recommend
this bill ought to
pass the intent of this bill is to Grant
municipalities the authority to collect
a public safety assessment based on
Hotel
occupancies the funds shall be used to
cut
increased costs of Municipal Services
associated with
tourism and transitory traffic These
funds shall be deposited in a capital
reserve tourism support fund and shall
not be part of the general
fund uh the bill specifies that the
voting procedures for the legislative
body to adopt these provisions and the
specific wording of the warrant shall
State the amount and manner of
collection if the majority votes yes the
public safety assessment shall apply on
board the town or city may also consider
resending its action in the same manner
as described in voting to adopt
it so here with us today we have people
that have traveled a long distance the
selectman and the police chief from the
town of Conway and so um I offer to
abbreviate my introduction to open the
floor to their expert testimony thank
you thank you will you take questions if
any representative PL is there any
amount specified in the bill is it not
capped could they it is I did not put
the amount in the bill I that could be
added later as an amendment but the um
the point of the bill is to Grant the
municipalities the authority to
to
um the authority to
um address this
assessment so one step at a time is the
way I kind of looked at
it if if if if the committee
um authorizes the municipalities to to
adopt this
assessment then we can also add an
amendment onto it with a dollar amount
uh the committee can add the am the the
dollar amount or committee can leave the
bill the way it is and let the municipal
just add the dollar amount to
it
okay yes representative fellows I had
two classes questions and this is just
about at the the town level I I don't
know what a public safety
assessment is if is that a tax or is
that somebody visiting the place in like
a um public sa like a safety inspection
and the other question is why is it
going to a capital reserve
account okay so first of the first thing
is or
this it's going to a capital reserve
account because it's not part of the
general
fund was a a way to separate this money
because this money is needed for um tour
for for expenses for for tourism and and
what was the second first question um is
it just a tax or is it some kind of
inspection
no it's a it's a it's an a it's a
um I guess it's like it's like a
fee because it's it's to it basically
going to go to um police and fire
because those are the things that are
that the expenses that go up with the
tourism
yes representative yes thank you Mr
chairman um just looking at this line
eight nine and 10 um I know you said
it's the intent was tourism but the way
I'm reading it I'm thinking maybe
municipalities could use this to maybe
augment their welfare budgets I know in
in you know okay as we as we talk about
transient welfare budgets are really
taking a hit
um uh other special Revenue fund could
could could could could this be used to
supplement or bolster uh the strained
welfare budgets of our towns well no
because that's why it's not part of the
general fund for those specific reasons
and I if if you're looking at the in the
bill line number five and number six is
really the heart of this bill the
legislative body of a municipality may
vote to collect a public safety
assessment based
on each occupancy of each from each
hotel that that's really the heart of
the the
bill and but but what you just
questioned about using the money for
something else that's that's why it gets
put into a separate account account not
fund yes
represent
thank you representative however I
direct your attention to line nine or
other special Revenue
fund oh well that was the what to title
the bill I mean what to title the
fund it's a special Revenue fund because
of just what the representative just
asked the question it can't be used for
anything else else no no no what what
this says is that shall be deposited in
a capital reserve fund or other special
Revenue fund as may be authorized by the
legislative body of the municipality so
in short it's not a fee it's a tax
because you're collecting a tax given to
the community to use any way they feel
like uh well the intent was to try and
not have that happen so I mean we're
this
approach chairman members of the
committee uh my name is Delan mccan
again uh happy to be here I've shared
some written testimony just going to add
a few points to that in the interest of
time um we are known uh as the city of
the open door we're incredibly proud of
that in Portsmouth uh we were proud of
all the folks that that come to our city
and you know if this was earlier in the
day I'm sure I could have convinced a
couple of you to come out here as any
mayor uh should take any opportunity to
talk about all the great restaurants
wants things to do in their city um but
I'm not I'm here to talk about really
the cost of of keeping that that door
open um and although we're proud it
costs a lot of money uh to keep that
keep the Chism uh coming in in terms of
fire trucks ladder trucks I mean you
know the amount a ladder truck cost to
be able to service a four to five story
Hotel you know it's not what a a typical
city or town uh is looking for a town
that is 23,000 that swells to the amount
of 100,000 has to have a police force uh
we're going through a process right now
in Portsmith of building or modifying
our existing uh police force and and the
questions are you know why do we need uh
as many police as we do uh in the city
and that's frankly because we grow to
about a 100,000 a times during the
summer and we need a police force that
you know um that's able to accommodate
uh all of that uh and do that safely you
know we need to invest uh in the fire
and police to make sure that all of
these good things uh continue uh to
happen and we want these you know we
understand the rooms and meals revenue
is a is a great benefit uh to the state
we collect over $30 million we receive
less than $2 million back because it's
based on population uh and we get that
you know we we wish that it was based on
population when it came to the county
tax it's assessed on us it's not it's
based on our our property values there
um but we understand we're a big part of
the state of New Hampshire and we are
willing to pull on the same rope as the
rest of the state we know that we're a
Frugal State uh but what we're asking
for and this bill asks for uh is the
right to to to have a little home rule
uh when it comes uh to this to be able
to self-determined that this is in the
best interest of the city of Portsmouth
and at the end of the day you know I've
been up here I think this is my fifth
year testifying in some form or the
other on a bill that is somewhat like
this and I'm really excited because I
think this Bill gets it right where
others have have failed previously this
was line to tourism fund to Market um
and and and market a business in the
tourism of a of a locality you know the
businesses should be doing that um you
know before it would go into the general
fund and I think there was some
questions uh you know what would that be
used for and it could be used to grow
other things that are not specifically
focused on this and I'm speaking on
behalf of this bill because what I
believe the intent of the bill is doing
and if there's amendments to to follow
that's up to you know all of you smart
people here today um it is so that we
can provide the things that the city has
to provide the number one reason we have
government and that's the public health
and safety of our citizens that is
strained uh by tourism um and it's borne
by the taxpayer a property tax that a
lot of people
uh can't afford even if they appreciate
the Vitality that it brings so happy to
answer any questions uh and I appreciate
your time here today thank you
representative PL first question that
comes to mind is isn't all that tourism
and transience boosting your property
tax values for the hotels and the
restaurants who benefit from that
traffic is so to repeat your question is
this captured in the property tax as it
stands today no um and the reason I
don't believe it's captured in the
property tax is that we have no ability
to look at a a business's revenues of
that so we make General assumtions um on
this in terms of the assessor's office
uh you know if we had a um you know if
we had a line by line of every you know
all the revenues that a uh that a hotel
makes we might more accurately reflect
that in a property tax but we have to
use the highest and best use of that
property and so I don't believe that we
can accurately depict how much uh this
Ames uh good afternoon afterno um so the
bill there's this sort of blank space in
this bill and also in your testimony the
bill would authorize the legislative
body of of Portsmouth to vote to collect
a public safety assessment on each
occupancy the room occupancy at the
hotel um that's it so what's the
assessment going to be it
doesn't it gives you a blank check so to
speak you can assess at 10% of the room
rate or 100% really there's nothing
there's no limit set here other than I
suppose your good judgment but another
municipality's good judgment might be
quite different shouldn't there be
something there and what should there be
certainly would support any language
that your good judgment uh would provide
uh on on this um you know I don't think
that you know we we govern at the
consent of the Govern you know if we put
forth a you know an unreasonable tax or
levy on the hotels then or fee whatever
we're calling it um it seems like you
know if we like it we call it a tax if
we don't like it we call you know we
like it we call it a fee if we don't
like it we call it a tax but you know
whatever you guys decide what I would
like you decide is that it's within the
realm of a municipality to say we can
assess what the state allows us to
assess for the cost born uh by this
hotel and I would certainly support and
I would up here you know uh cheering you
on if you said this is reasonable at
this amount um could certainly support
something along uh those
lines okay thank you I think we're going
to have to work on
that yes represent it's hard to see
thank you mayor taking my question um it
does seem like we'll have a work session
and for me I know the Portsmouth area
very well I think it would be helpful to
have some Ram hers actually from you
about what type of funds you feel you
need to raise and again whether it would
be better um to have a percent or just
so much per room night um you know on
the flly it's tough to think you know
per Center room I I want to make sure
you know uh I understand you know
Portsmith you know might be different
than another part of the state um and so
wouldn't want to be um uh you know
prejudicing the support of other parts
of the state when the average you know a
hotel night would be you know 250 bucks
uh in Portsmith um versus another part
of the state where it might be less and
so a a stock dollar amount might be
different um than another part but I'm
happy to give us context yeah and I'm
happy to uh to come back here and um uh
and bring uh some more of the folks on
our side that could give you more of
that data uh that might be more
helpful I think to that point are
you experiencing a shortfall for law
enforcement or fire uh prevention is is
there a certain amount and I think you
don't necessarily have to answer that
right now but excuse me excuse me as
part of the representative's question
that is going to help us kind of
understand what so I I think when we
look at the budget of the city of
portsman it's about $138 million of that
uh 111 is operating um and you know
police accounts for 13 million fire is
11 million you know uh schools obviously
about half as it is with most uh
municipalities and then govern General
government's about 23 million um what we
found is that we were not competitive in
the last uh 3 years we had not ever lost
a a hire to somewhere another
municipality until last year uh we had
to have a you know hard look in terms of
attracting and retaining police officers
I believe very much in our police and
fire force I think you know all the nice
things we get to do government uh are
because we have we keep the the public
safety uh the public health uh at the
Forefront of that um and so we had to
increase wages there we're also going
through um you know a an assessment of
our current police station you know a
capital project is not something that I
think this would be uh designed uh to to
to offset um but here's what I'm trying
to solve I guess at the highest level um
many people come up to me uh and just
wonder why do we have to have so many
cops um and I know the answer because
like yourselves you know I sit and I
look at data all day long and I and I
see uh the uh the need uh for the police
because I see the growth in our
community um that's really hard for
somebody that's living on a fixed income
that sees their property values go up
but don't want to sell their house and
and move uh and then they're going to be
paying a a greater and greater share of
taxes that's ultimately what I would
like to uh decouple a little bit and
that's the growth and popularity of
Tourism with having people uh be forced
to to to move out of our community and
taking with them all of the history that
they have of Portsmouth of an older
Portsmouth a different Portsmouth uh
that you know doesn't make the papers as
much but you know is built by uh the
Navy Yard the Air Force Base uh and
that's what um we're trying to solve
we're doing in you know different ways
in terms of creating you know what
you've allowed for the senior and
disabled tax exemptions we've increased
those to larger Parts than anywhere in
the State uh but this would help us
align the tourm the state which we
believe is a beneficial to the entire
State um and the people of Portsmith
that don't always think of New Hampshire
when they think of their finances uh as
we do uh in the city of Portsmouth
okay
others yes representative fellows um I I
know this bill has shown up before I I
think one time I heard it in um
Municipal and County and I'm just
wondering um and I don't have the rsas
with me but I'm not clear about what
what sorts of establishment this would
apply to it says on line six it applies
to
hotels do you know does it apply to I
think you're GNA find and so um you know
I I claim to be smart enough to know
what I don't know um and I don't know
all of the intricacies of the bill and
I'm going to leave that to your good
judgment in terms of doing the work of a
legislature and and crafting this in the
narrowest terms of legislation that
allows the greatest benefit the highest
you know points of this I think making
sure that that hotels and you could
limit that in terms of number of people
that that you know stay in that room uh
to cut out uh the smaller airbnbs that
might not be able to uh to to pay uh
this you could you know again you know
capture the the amount or percentage all
of those things what what I'm here to to
support is the state that there is a
cost that's not borne uh by uh the
property tax when it comes to assessing
commercial buildings that engage in in
hotels and that this would better
capture that cost and allow us uh to
continue to provide the services that
possible yes representative sodi thank
you for taking the question have you
explored other options like um
potentially an auxiliary voluntary fire
department and police force Maybe it's
also help serves a farm club like in
baseball like because you're going up
the ranks in order to um well deal with
the your problem that your safety issues
that you're speaking of yep so um there
are uh some of our our our neighboring
uh communities have um more volunteer
they they've some of them have moved
away uh from that I think it um you know
for the number of sworn offers that we
have in in in ports it would it would I
think it's closer to 78 it would be
tough to find that in a um in a uh in a
volunteer capacity um you know uh from a
uh and you know from the fire uh a lot
of it is uh you know certainly you know
Portsmith burned down three times not on
my watch you know was a couple hundred
years ago when we built things in Wood
um but uh a lot of what we're seeing um
right now is the response to the uh you
know a lot of opioid um EMS visits and
we have relationships with neighboring
towns uh to provide EMS Services uh for
those neighboring towns uh as well um I
think it would be a you know while I'm
always looking for um you know saving
money uh that's big part of the job I
don't think it's feasible to operate the
city of portsmouth's police and fire uh
as a volunteer force uh certainly now um
and in the summer when we're about
100,000 people uh we need trained people
that are going to be able to respond to
them okay thank you thank you very much
enjoy the rest of your day appreciate
you get powering through and so I can go
thanks okay we have a lot of these to
um uh I can't read this that well uh the
oh I'm sorry Paul
deglin
Paul I know right thank you Mr chairman
in the interest of time and efficiency
would it be okay if um Town manager John
Eastman joins me we'll do two cards in
one sure chair may I ask the gentleman
to spell his last name for me absolutely
sure do you have a spare
pen just in case you run out of Inc it's
d e g l i a n g
e n g e l and as you thought it's
D very close I applaud your bravery for
trying the the first g is silent it's
pronounced
Ireland okay and you are joined by John
Eastman yes my name is John Ean I'm the
town
manager uh thank you again and thank you
for um powering through my last name as
well as lunch can't be easy when we're
all low blood
sugar
um like the uh city of Portsmith the
town of Conway would like you to support
this bill um as you know uh Resort and
destination communities place a
disproportionate burden on the taxpayer
as you know our tax system uh here in
New Hampshire does not allow for
different r commercial and residential
and we just cannot address you know
these types of
expenses um later you'll hear from our
police chief you know lots of folks
consider Conway a small uh northern town
yet uh if you look at our police force
um it Rivals much bigger communities and
that's a necessity because of
visitorship we're talking about hotels
today and you know lodging facilities um
the development potentially spurred by
the pandemic has been unprecedented I
have been the in service for the town of
Conway for these last 33
years um prior to being the deputy Town
manager I was both the town's engineer
and director of Public
Works um so we're talking about safety
we're talking about the disproportionate
B burden placed on our uh police and our
fire but for a moment I'd also like to
talk about a different kind of safety
and health uh which is our sewage
treatment
plant we have a biological
process right there are organisms there
are colonies of organisms that live in
our process that
consume the sewage and make it safe to
discharge that needs to be balanced with
our
flows in the last three years Conway has
permitted through our planning board
five hotels that's 500 new rooms in
three
years
50% of our tax bills go out of area we
have entire neighborhoods that are
vacant Monday through
Friday we're struggling to manage the
flows that Peak every weekend that Peak
during Christmas Vacation due to the ski
crowd in February and that peak in July
and
August there are Technologies to help us
retrofit our
plant they're in the Millions
we as as the um mayor from portsman said
we can't capture these costs through
connection fees through impact initial
taxation we urge you to support this
Bill thank you for your
time representative
PL what's presented to us so far is a
blank
check is there
a evidence excuse me me examples from
other states how this is done that we
could use as a
to why it was presented with your
request for your input and your good
judgment to determine what's tolerable I
understand that similar bills have been
before this body in the past and and
didn't pass and perhaps it was because
of the amounts I can say that you know
know as an advert skier um I do travel
across the United States to other Resort
towns uh and I can see that there is you
know a
percentage you see nods going up and
down I understood that there was a a
blank amount or initially discussed uh
and that a percentage of that would go
to the uh inke Keepers the lodging
properties for their troubles um I I
guess I assume it's because they wanted
input from this body and they they were
hoping that it would go on uh you know
to an amendment and further
representative yes representative
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman so
let's just assume we enact the law
exactly as it's been drafted so you now
have the blank check as an administrator
making a proposal
locally what is your proposal
well that's a good question um locally
it's been talked about as uh $2 a room
night with um between 10 and 20% of that
establishment thank you oh okay thank
you uh yes representative fellows thank
thank you Mr chairperson um so actually
that that was like part part of my my
question and that's answered but I'm
wondering when you you have a lot of
those airbnbs up in Conway so how how
would they be taxed per room or per
bedroom
or um
per per night of rental per the
property so if I rented an Airbnb for
Friday Saturday and Sunday um under the
amount we just talked about that would
that would be $6 it's three nights one
property whether you
again there's discussion sliding scales
this one sleeps 16 this one sleeps
four um you know keeping things simple
uh walking before we run and again
although I don't know because I'm not
the spons sponsor of the bill um I
assume the reason it was presented that
way is for the input of this this
body representative ores thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
so at $2 a room a night how much money
year so we've calculated between uh
airbnbs
um hotel motel um b&bs roughly 3,000
rooms and the um the work that's been
done in Conway though it's not too a
science it's roughly 50% occupancy year
round because you do have some slow
times but in the busy times uh in Conway
North Conway we're busy at least nine
months out of the year so we're we would
estimate about 50% which would be about
$1,500 excuse me500 rooms times two
$3,000 a day you're just slightly under
a million
dollars that's the estimate for the year
yes sir followup hello so how much money
do you need to upgrade your sewage
treatment
systems we just contracted with a
consulting firm we went through the
usual and customary RS fq process um
we're not to the RFP process yet um but
that's costing us uh we think in the
order of
$350,000 to do the study in preliminary
engineering and very very ROM rough
order of
magnitude uh we're looking in the
vicinity of uh7 to9
million we don't know what's going to
happen in the future which is is why
again having this be
ongoing you know seems to be the best
approach to us uh at the the certainly
the magnitude that's being proposed here
in the last five minutes uh it seems
quite doable and I think someone else
asked you know do you have models has
this been done elsewhere uh you know I
can give you a list as long as my last
name which is pretty long I understand
um and where this is how it's being
handled followup please follow up so if
you are going to raise a million dollars
and you need much more than that to
upgrade your sewer system it sounds like
you're going to still come up way short
so how are you going to well of course
we're going to raise that money through
bonding we'll have 20 years to service
that debt uh and by the time we get
there we'll have new things we'll have
to do because of the disproportionate
you know burden that a destination
Community places
follow follow so the previous mayor
mentioned opioid so are you in need of
funds to handle like tourists coming in
drug use additional fire police maybe
for that or not our police chief is here
and I would prefer to defer to him uh
but yes I mean if you you've been to
Conway I'm certain and uh there's some
shopping there I mean what an idea right
you're going to come to a place place
that has mountains rivers skiing hiking
all active
Pursuits and if there are certain family
members that aren't interested in
activity or if the weather's bad let's
add the shopping the shoplifting gangs
alone that require you know again the
police chief will talk about that but
our our staff in the detective
department to say nothing of
patrolman is comparable to No One our
you okay thank you very much and if you
could just tell me the name of your
police chief we'll call him up next
that' be uh Chief Chris mattity mat a
Tei
okay chair I just have to squeeze into
F good after afternoon Chris mattye I'm
a resident of Conway and the chief of
Conway so I can tell you um I moved to
Conway about 20 years ago um I've been
on the police force for 19 years I've
been the police chief for three and a
half years and one thing I can tell you
is the two gentleman before he had
stated the town is nothing like it was
when I moved up here 20 years ago um we
are adding three new hotels within the
next year which will be approximately
350 to 400 beds
uh that brings hotels don't build unless
they think they can fill the rooms we
have restaurants being built we have uh
houses being converted to short-term
rentals I have two in my neighborhood
now um and I'm not here to discuss any
issues with that I have nothing against
them and I welcome the vacationers I
want them to come up because that's the
economy that we've built Our Town up up
you know upon That's the basis of our
our community I have two children a 20
soon to be 22y old soon to be 14 uh
sorry 16-year-old and they will not be
able to live in Conway so I will be
moving soon uh when I retire so I can be
with them wher they
land uh my house in the recent
assessment just doubled in in value so
my taxes are going up fortunately I can
afford my taxes right now but uh I'm
seriously concerned we have a serious
problem in the town and it's now
becoming a crisis where we are taxing
people out of the
Town um and I contribute to that because
I put forth a pretty hefty budget of
about $4.6 million a year so let me tell
you a little about the police department
um we are between 9 and 10,000 residents
due to uh based on our census I think
the latest census was
9700 if we were a town of just 9700 and
we were a bedroom community I estimate
our police force would be somewhere
between 16 and 18 and I get those
numbers based on similar towns and I
have those towns with between 9 and
like other towns that have colleges in
them Plymouth for example the the police
force is a little bit larger than you
would think for a residence of 4,000
people uh that Police Department I think
is 11 or 12 rightly so because of the
amount of people that come through just
like with Conway we are not staff for
9700 people uh we have 23 officers 24
full-time sworn officers one acts as a
prosecutor so we actually have 23 on the
road to include includ myself and
lieutenant and I do try to get on the
road as much as possible but like I said
we'd be somewhere in that vicinity of
approximately 17 officers if we did not
have the elastic community that we have
On Any Given weekend I shouldn't say
weekend from basically July 3rd fourth
through the end of August we have
anywhere from 30 to 40,000 people in
town we are in the Mount Washington
Valley so Conway is the epicenter of
that so even those that are staying
outside of town flock to Conway the town
of Conway so that we have a very elastic
Community like I stated so our police
force is based on that I think what's
different about Conway than most other
vacation areas such as let's say the
cape or um coastal towns in Maine is we
like our Our Town manager said we're
busy 9 to 10 months out of the year so I
had heard when the mayor was up here
from Portsmouth why don't we have
auxiliary or part time we need to keep
that Staffing because we're busy about 9
to 10 months out of the year
um V uh the the winters when we get snow
hopefully we get hit again tonight um
the that will bring more people in
through the rest of the winter through
the end of February into March
especially on weekends because people
will be coming up to ski we have five
ski mountains in the area within 40
minutes of Conway so again Conway is
that
epicenter the issue that I have is each
year we put forward a budget we try to
be as as conscientious as we can to the
taxpayers but we do need more staff last
year I asked for an additional
dispatcher just so you know we have
seven dispatchers
full-time uh along with our 24 sworn
personnel we have 35 full-time staff
members at the department to include
support
staff I do need a couple more officers
but every year when I try to write that
in the budget I hesitate because there
are other things that we need so I just
add a little more to our overtime fund
because we have young officers that are
willing to work that and it's cheaper to
pay the overtime than is to hire new
Personnel because you're not paying the
extra benefits
if you take the extra officers we have
you figure 17 to 23 we're talking five
to six more officers at an average of
about $100,000 an officer when you hire
them at 55,000 a year plus Insurance
Plus retirement and any other additional
benefits so you're looking at a half
million to about
$600,000 um just in extra Staffing and
of course that gets larger as the
officers stay on and they get their pay
raises each year that goes directly to
the taxpayer it's not the taxpayers
fault that we have to have that many
officers but then again like I said we
are a vac vacation community so we
welcome them up without them we wouldn't
we wouldn't if without the tourist we
wouldn't have a base of our economy so I
think supporting this bill will help
greatly in offsetting some of those
costs because as I stated we are going
to have to add and I'll end with this we
have a department that was built 35 36
years ago I have asked the taxpayers for
about 8 million million do to not only
renovate the department we have but to
which is about 7500 Square ft the study
that we just paid for um states that we
need between 50 and 70% more room 50% at
the current Staffing up to 70% 25 to 30
years out so we now have proposed not
only a renovation of our current space
but we're asking for an additional 5200
Square ft to accommodate the current
Staffing as well as the growth that we
anticipate in the future
that's a lot of money to ask the
taxpayers of Conway to put forth um and
with the recent assessments with the
difference in the increase in values
between residential and Commercial
that's going to fall on the taxpayers
it's going to be about 80 to $100 more
in the average home a year and that's a
lot to ask especially when their taxes
have already some of them have doubled
so I ask you to support this bill
because towns like us towns like
Portsmouth need this and in Conway like
I said we are not just a two or three
month a year um increase in our
population due to tourism where I can
hire four or five six part-time officers
Hampton uses that model they have just
as many part-time officers as they do I
think full-time officers that model
works for them because they're busy for
about three to four months out of the
year that doesn't work for
Conway thank you thank
you yes thank you Mr chairman thank you
chief for coming down um I can relate to
a population that swells I'm from
Littleton and our population goes from
5,000 to 20,000 in the course of a day
we a lot of the same concerns that
you're hearing we hear too um I've heard
from the the the mayor I've heard from
you I've heard the intent from the the
prime sponsor was to for these this to
enable municipalities to essentially tax
hotels I'm boil it down to that and with
that specifically go to Emergency
Services police fire ambulance and
whatnot and it sounds and I and I we go
to Conway a lot and uh I know exactly
where what you're talking about are you
worried the way the bill is written
because I I alluded to this when the
prime sponsor introduced it that there
maybe opportunity to maybe siphon money
away from the intent the way the
legislation is written uh my colleague
uh picked up on the same thing I did
there there seems to be some open
open-ended verbiage that you know we
could make a case that some you know a
park is good for you know we need to put
money towards a Park which is not a bad
thing but the intent is to go to right
to where you're you what you need and to
support your services so do you think
that the the language as is adequately
ensures that your needs are going to be
met or are there things that we could do
to strengthen that well as far as where
the money is spent I'm going to ask for
it and it's up to my um my town
officials to to siphon off whatever
whatever they they deem necessary for
the for the police department but um you
know I guess I don't really have a
straightforward answer for that kind of
above my pay grade as far as the way
it's written but I would hate to see uh
those of you in this room not support it
just because we have to work out the
fine details I think it's way too
important for that um you know I I I I
tell a story I know we're stretch for
time but I was next door snowblowing my
neighbors's uh yard the other today and
her husband just passed and she is on a
single income now uh elderly woman and
she came over to me and gave me a hug
and said I'll support your new police
department you need it but I don't know
how I can afford it and I think that
really wraps up um what I'm trying to
say here is I think that people we have
a phenomenal community that support the
police I can only speak for the police
and I think there are people that want
to support what we're trying to do but I
think a lot of them were asking too much
um and uh the the the the other fear
that I have is that people like my my
children are not going to be able to
live in Conway they can't AF I can't
afford my home right now if I had to buy
it from
myself um it's just too expensive and
luckily I I I moved in a few years ago
so before the rates went up so I think
this is needed and I'm sorry if I didn't
questions yes repres fellows I just
wanted to ask you if you you know what
you're talking about is you're saying
property taxes are so high a lot of
people can't afford to live in your town
and it and it's certainly not an issue
that's only related to Conway so I'm
wondering if you have some ideas of why
property taxes are so high well I can
tell you that the the amount of second
homes that we have in the community uh
people are coming up and they they want
the homes in Conway and they're willing
to spend the money to to purchase them
um they're paying in cash a lot of times
they might be outbidding people who have
to finance and it's paying more and that
this is something that's that's happened
like you said across the state paying
more for houses which has inflated the
values I can tell you that I um I lived
in fryberg main up to four years ago I
moved to Conway so I could hopefully
have a shot at this job um and luckily
fortunate for me um I did uh get the nod
to to take on the Chief's position and I
think it's important that I live in
Conway I think it's important that I'm a
taxpayer but I can tell you that um four
years ago I would not have been able to
purchase the house that I live in so
like I said the the the value of my
house went up 86% in the recent
valuation the reason for that um I don't
know all the all the all the in ins and
outs of there but I never would have
thought that three and a half years ago
November of 2019 when I moved in my
house that my house would be worth 86%
more than it is uh than it was then
you
next up representative
Edgar
yes we still and I'll just uh say we
still have a lot of pin cards to go
through so it ask that as you come up
think about what hasn't been said and
try
details
uh thank you Mr chairman in committee
for uh taking my
testimony um I I will make it brief I'll
cut out most of it has been awful lot
said already um again my name is Mike
Edgar uh I represent Hampton and this uh
this bill is is close to me Hampton uh
also Str strong L supports this this
bill so I'll just read a few few of the
sentences off of the uh of what I have
here and um basically it's I want to
emphasize it's a a local option and it's
a fee it's local option it's not for
everybody maybe most of the towns and
and cities wouldn't pick up on this uh
take the option and it is a fee it's not
a tax it's supposed to be going towards
the uh basically the users to a certain
degree to support that um and I am a
co-sponsor of this bill and I am maybe
you you all can help me I'm trying to
find trying to find my glasses here but
uh oh there you
are thank you
um this I want to repeat again that this
bill enables municipalities to enact a
local option Hotel occupancy fee um any
the Hotel designation as Hotel was was
actually originally put in this in some
previous bills because it there's
specific uh uh definitions for that in
the
rsas um it's an attempt to provide some
funds to offset the additional Municipal
expenditures that result in increased
pressure on the local property
tax pretty much now I'll I'll jump to
the bottom and please support uh hb1
1254 and authorize this local option fee
for
municipalities see if there's any any
questions thank you any
questions
represent representative PL yes do you
have any idea what that fee should
be I I do yeah but it's what had been
proposed in the past and it was in uh
basically a couple other bills that had
been previously submitted one of them
was back in uh 2020 uh
hb160 but I have a a section here or
possible amendment to include some of
those limits which is basically would
have been as for before which was $2 in
occupancy or a certain percentage not to
representative thank you thank you very
Aly I was going representative Susan
elme uh city of
Lebanon
uh I think I authored one of these
bills and we I've been doing this for
quite a while and um I am speaking for
the
non-tourist urban centers I call them
Urban hubs some of them are towns some
of us are cities uh but on we are the
center
of of uh a lot of towns that are bedroom
communities and they have much lower
property taxes than we do because we
provide the social service network we
provide uh the shopping we provide the
hospital we
provide
on on Al we a lot of other things
Lebanon is a industrial Hub as well as a
uh has the largest malls in our region
uh and has a lot of startups has a lot
of uh nonprofit not tax paying on social
services that are used by the entire
region uh we have a free transit system
Lebanon provides a fair Lebanon and
Dartmouth College provide a fair amount
of the cost of that he goes
to 15 177 communities in Vermont and New
Hampshire
um and
because of this we have a police force
which is twice as large as the police
force per capita of any place in Grafton
County uh for the same reasons you've
been hearing and we have um a fire
department which is mostly at this point
EMTs uh people responding to Opium
problem to opiate problems opioid
problem s uh and people responding to
the large number growing number of aged
people that live in our community but
also in the communities around
us and
[Music]
um we've been trying to figure out for
some time within the tax system of New
Hampshire on there is almost nothing
that a community can do to raise money
except the property tax we also get a
property tax on cars of residents but
not nothing that we can do to raise
money from the people coming from
outside uh
the the lodging tax which I think it
should be called rather than a hotel
tax uh is one
that does not really affect the people
in the towns living around around us
they rarely they
will eat in inside the city but we don't
get more than our population from the
rooms and meals
tax uh and they
um and we do get a
pilt a a pretty good payment in L of
taxes now from from the largest hospital
in Northern New England uh which is
mostly paying for the extra expenses
that they create for us but um we can't
charge Pils to a lot of the nonprofits
because they um don't have enough money
to get their services done as it
is so
on
WE this is why I've been pushing pushing
for this for some time on the college
towns have similar kinds of problems but
in in fact uh we absorb most of the
overload of Dartmouth College in Lebanon
rather than
Hanover doing it uh our property taxes
are the highest north of
Claremont uh I believe in all of Grafton
County so um and this situation occurs I
mean Claremont is in this situation also
uh they have been providing less
Services usually so so they hadn't quite
gotten to this part of the problem yet
but but um there are a lot of towns
scattered around around the state that
are not tourist towns but that are
um productive towns that can't figure
out how to maintain the services that
they're
providing and that does include sewage
but I don't think sewage is a public
safety issue and the public safety issue
I think is a large part of of this um
the both for emergency health conditions
and for and that I suppose could be
sewage uh
and and the police and the
fire so thank you thank you oh and I do
think that that it needs a lot of
tighter wording in various places okay
well we will have a work session on this
bill um
yes thank you Mr chairman representative
Al if I may ask a quick question for you
and and you you alluded to this right at
the end of your testimony saying you
need
work on some of the language if it was
to go into effect right now
uh the line on line
10 such funds shall be used to augment
funding for the cost of Municipal
Services associated with the increase in
tourism and transient
traffic you think right now as that
stands would be clear enough that these
funds would only be used for that
regardless of how they're where they're
placed and where they we've had the
question a couple times this morning and
that's what I wanted to to to bring up
well the mechanism that we're looking at
would on almost entirely I I put people
up occasionally in hotels in in in
Lebanon but on because I don't have much
of a
house uh they it it is based mostly on
people coming
in on that are going to be sleeping
there
and for that reason I think that the
transit traffic part it wouldn't even
need to say tourism because tourism is
transient
also uh transient by the way has nothing
to do with homeless people in this case
it has to do with with you've got
somebody coming in from California to
something follow up follow up thank you
more
specifically what I'm getting at is are
you concerned at all that these funds
that are collected would be spent
somewhere else that's what I'm trying to
yes I think that that it does need a
fair amount of definition in a whole
bunch of areas starting with lodging
rather than
Hotel okay yes represent both
representative um thank you for taking
my question um regarding um well I I'm
from Plymouth Plymouth is a small town
but similar issues than most of the
larger towns and I think we have 13
police officers by the way not 10 or 12
because uh I'm on the select board and
it's great to have a full staff but it's
uh kind of like a horror show to try to
like fund everything but you said uh
similar bills were put in in the past
that you may have even uh submitted um
what was the outcome of that and is this
bill um perhaps more provides more
clarity to how we should proceed on
this I think the the there's been
a something of a conflict between
tourist towns and non-tourist towns that
are having identical
problems
on and I I would bet that that Portsmith
for instance is has a lot more of the
features of taking care of people in the
outskirts that we have um but uh than
they were talking about but um it it has
been difficult
dividing uh on agreeing on what we were
doing each time and and and this bill
um is the first of two I think that were
put in and the second one bowed out so
that the first one could go
forward um I do think that
um that the problem part of the problem
has been that but part of the problem
has simply been that
um
the um the there are a lot more towns
that are bedroom communities in this
state than there are towns that receive
people during the day Lebanon is up to
15,000 population at this point the
mayor claims
16 uh but on as of 15 years ago they
told us that we had about 35,000 during
the day I would I would bet give the
number of businesses we've got now that
it's it's more like
50 but representative spillsbury thank
you Mr chairman you've made a very
interesting distinction between uh the
towns that have this problem because of
Tourism primarily versus a town that has
this problem for other reasons and you
also mentioned Claremont I don't
represent Claremont but it's adjacent to
charl town and very much affects uh its
surrounding towns because like Lebanon
it's it's a shopping Hub um and it's a
shopping Hub at a state border in a um
sales taxfree state that you know
derives an awful lot of its activity
from that
Advantage Claremont on the other hand
has virtually no meaningful lodging
activity so if if the if the concept is
that we have a
problem and it's a shared problem in
these different
iterations but the solution is to raise
it off of lodging what happens to a town
that suffers from the burdens of being a
regional shopping center and a regional
Social Services Center but doesn't have
tax this um this is a major defect in
our taxation system
and I don't
know I don't know what we I frequently
don't know what we do about
CL it's a conundrum we have sent them
some major industry lately okay thank
woodcock
thank you so much uh Representatives I
will try to get us back on track um to
answer some of the questions I hadn't I
intended to uh follow up I was only a
co-sponsor but I just want to get us
back two minutes because like you this
11:30 meeting is now 1:30 um first off
we have question after listening to some
of the dialogue there's an amendment
that's been is needed there's not a
question about that at all uh we like to
work at that I like to bring you back to
how this started with r pres buo and and
uh Paige and I in Conway uh this year
with this particular Bill we met with a
selectman uh and dialogued with them
about these issues uh they seem
relatively vague now as you see it in
print uh but we wanted specifically a
couple things we wanted it to be
enabling legislation we did not want it
to be an open blank check for any money
coming in as a slush fund what we wanted
was a fee in this case we talked about
$1 to $2 per night per occupy per room
but strictly for health and safety
strictly for in a account that was a
dedicated incumbent account for police
Fire EMS and Wastewater the four health
and safety pieces for our town which has
been extended be and overused and
overcharge because of the the tourist
Community which we are which is terrific
except for these costs can't don't
replicate what a town of 8,000 to 10,000
people use all right um and we don't get
it back any other way so this was the
idea of having this fund of uh a night
nightly occupancy if the room is
occupied for that particular light not
to exceed $2 per night um there is some
language between lines 20 and 30 to talk
about how he did that but that's because
it was open to different types of uh
Municipal structures within the state
thinking that a Portsmouth clearly is
going to be different from a Hampton and
a Lebanon and a Conway each have
different forms of government so that's
why it's vague we can clearly tighten
that up without question and we had
talked talked about
um you know someone said well why you
why you want to assess a a safety fee
because it's not like all of us have
traveled for usually either business or
unfortunately for a funeral or for
vacation and we go in and get a room if
you look in the website today in North
Conway they start about a buck and a
half and go to $500 or $600 depending
what you want that night at the room we
aren't thinking about the extra fee of
$12 that's it's disposable income
however it's not a disposable cost of
the community uh as you heard we had
fire we had five this time last year
five fire departments two full-time with
minimum labor and three volunteer uh
supported by uh Chiefs we now have four
and it's going to be three before next
year comes because we can't afford to
supplement the Staffing we need we can't
afford to keep the the cost of the fire
equipment up we have the police
constantly out uh over over tax we don't
have enough Police Department once again
we can't make that a relative cost based
on 10,000 10,000 people on that
Community uh the property tax they
already talk about and chief M talked
about the police pce but we have these
are strictly costs that are tourist
focused uh and they are Public Safety
costs I just want to bring us back down
into that uh realm that that was our
intent when we started this enabling
dedicated funds specifically for health
with health and safety uh and and
clearly as I see this now it's it's not
a out of the out of the uh off the all
suggestion uh in that the selectman and
the town has been very supportive of
this uh as we've gone through the whole
process talking about over the months
unfortunately as you as you see some of
is is is relatively vague in terms of
because of I told you the different
types of government and the line 10 that
someone just brought up a minute ago uh
represent is accurate this is this is
that that's exactly what it's for it's
not for anything else it's not for more
Parks more Fields it's just for health
and safety because of the cost that that
that we can't we can't absorb and
clearly is getting more it's bringing
it's bringing more and more tourists in
New Hampshire from the time you get down
in Portsmouth all the way up to CS
County um so it's that's what this is
and I appreciate your concern your
consideration we' be happy to work with
you on on an amendment I'm sure
representative Paige and I would as well
uh to bring this all together to make it
easier for your committee I'd be happy
to answer questions but I know it's
getting late thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
Tibido KY Tibido uh Vice chairman bard
of selectman Conway uh pretty much
everything that I had on my list has
been touched on except for uh one
particular item uh first of all I'd like
to just go back to the fire and
Emergency Services
uh talked with the fire chief yesterday
who was unable to make it today the uh
fire departments in Conway answered over
3,000 calls for service last year in a
in a uh a town with a population of uh
10,000 people that is a ridiculous
amount of of fire service calls at 3,000
they're averaging around 10 calls a day
okay that's because we have 40 uh, and
sometimes maybe even 50,000 people there
at any given time on a weekend or during
a busy week okay you've been told all
this I won't dwell on it um but I would
like to say this much there are is some
opposition to this bill the hospitality
Association I don't see any
representation from them here today um
has been adamant about opposing this
bill saying that it's going to be
detrimental to
tourism um and as uh representative
Woodcock just said any place that he's
ever been there's always some kind of a
fee attached to the bottom line of the
hotel bill state state fee County fee
local fee uh no one seems to have any
discouragement about any of these uh
fees as you travel around the country
but more importantly uh I would submit
to you that the opposite is actually
true it not only won't hurt tourism it
is ultimately going to help in the long
run because the people that live here
and work in the tourist tra cannot
afford to stay here they they are being
taxed out of their homes you heard the
police chief say that he's being taxed
out of his home and being a police chief
is a good job uh that that's not a uh
that's not a lowincome deal okay so if
he can't afford it you can imagine
what's going on further on down the line
uh the people that live here and work in
the tourist trads can't afford to stay
here in fact they are leaving and we
know this because the resulting new
hotels are unable to open existing
hotels are operating short staff and
it's almost impossible to get a
breakfast or a lunch on a Tuesday or
Wednesday because most of the hotel most
of the restaurants in the Mount
Washington Valley are closed due to
short staffing okay uh if the out of
control property tax Trend continues
there'll be nobody left to service the
tourist trade so it's important to think
about this very carefully and to allow
those of us that want to have this fee
attached to these rooms to offset some
of these costs and ultimately keep our
taxes down to something that can be
affordable to have this legislation uh
if there's nobody left to Ser service
the tourist trade where will they go and
what will we do because we are totally
dependent on them at this point in time
thank you for your time thank you any
questions yes representative
fellows thank you so you mentioned how
um housing is unaffordable for for most
of the
people that work in Conway and a lot of
people who live there now yes so the
estimate on what this bill could
possibly do for Conway would give you
maybe a million dollars extra Revenue in
a year and that would help a little bit
but you don't think that it
would be able to make housing
significant ific L more affordable I
wouldn't think and and what do you think
might be able to do that that is is uh
that is an excellent question and this
is not the answer okay this is simply
one piece to a puzzle that the board of
selectman have been working on for quite
some time uh we are working in
conjunction with the uh planning board
whose chair is here tonight I don't know
if he's going to speak or not um to to
work on things uh like uh EXT
expanding a density requirement so that
they can build more houses and a smaller
piece of ground uh things of that nature
we're working on the master plan the
master plan has a lot of Provisions in
there for some form of affordable
housing um this is not the beginning the
middle and the end this is just a piece
of the puzzle that will be very very
helpful that will assist in getting us
to that end um it's not the answer it's
okay thank you very much thank you for
your
time now this next card I'm sorry I
can't read the first name it starts with
mcran um mayor well it's a second card
brand pardon
me well good afternoon thank you my name
is Heidi milbrand I own and operate
Pleasant viewb and breakfast up in
Bristol and I'm also the immediate past
president of the New Hampshire bed and
breakfast Association I sit on the board
of directors of the New Hampshire
lodging and Restaurant Association and
I'm also a member of the Lakes Region
Ben breakfast Association and as a side
note as I'm sitting here
listening I'm hearing people talking
about their their property taxes I will
trade my tax bill with anybody I pay
over $112,000 in taxes for my
property so I'm here to speak against
hb1
1254 and here we go again I think this
is the fifth time I've been down here to
speak against this bill my business sits
in the beautiful Newfound Lake Region
and we rely heavily on tourists
legitimate lodging establishments
already collect 8 and half% meals and
Rental tax adding another fee to my
guests will deter them from staying and
reduce my business when I travel nothing
frustrates me more than seeing my bill
from a lodging facility that includes a
city tax occupancy tax state tax and an
airport tax if I happen to stay near an
airport legitimate lodging businesses
are already undermined by Airbnb vrbos
and other online book looking companies
as well as real estate rental companies
who can work outside State Rags will
towns be required or able to collect
this fee from these online bookings
according to their stats they rent a lot
of rooms what upsets me the most about
this bill is that it is discriminatory
and prejudicial why are you only going
after lodging why not require
restaurants gas stations retail shops
every business out there and why should
my business my life in business be
responsible for funding towns that are
incompetent in their budgeting I see
that these revenues collected are
intended to be used for Public Safety
don't get me wrong I'm not against
public safety I love my cops I love my
firemen my cops have a great dog that
comes to visit me every once in a while
but why should my business be the only
one responsible to help fund this budget
line does not everyone benefit from
Public Safety Services so you want to
tax one business for the benefit of a
city's bottom line and I should point
out via the meals and rooms tax we uh we
already have and are giving money back
to the towns for this purpose and yet
there's a bill later on to reduce this
tax and how is this tax going to be
enforced does it give the state the
right to audit me to make sure I'm
giving my town the fee Big Brother's
truly watching me and what about admin
cost to the town how will they be paid I
also see that in order for this bill's
requirement to go into effect town will
need to vote on it I shudder at this
thought particularly with no cap on the
fee I know how my people in my town
think and they'll they're going to view
this as a property tax reduction and
it's going to get voted in without
regard to its long-term
consequences this bill is being proposed
by larger cities is a money grab for
them the amount that small towns could
collect is inconsequential town of
Bristol two two legitimate lodging
facilities two just in the town of
Bristol in the other towns total of
three other legitimate lodging
facilities around Newfound Lake in fact
it's going to put an additional burden
on me the town and my fellow legitimate
lodging Partners to collect and remit
yet another tax and fee so on behalf of
my of my fellow inke Keepers and on
behalf of the the New Hampshire lodging
and Restaurant Association our lodging
property members it's a hard no on this
and I I want to find and I want to know
where are all these
properties that are for this tax this
bill this this fee where are they why
are they not here we're only hearing
from the towns we're not hearing from
other lodging facilities that want this
so I urge you to truly think about what
you're doing this is New Hampshire Live
Free or Die not
taxachusetts thank
you thank you representative PL couldn't
the intent of this bill be POS met if
the state gave the rooms and meals tax a
bigger cut to the towns and cities
that's up to you I totally agree right
now I know I know M&R is I know for the
$200,000 yes represent ORS thank you Mr
chair excuse me thank you for taking my
question so if you had mentioned the
other Bill about meals and rooms so if
that tax was to be reduced is that good
you personally
it's you're going to reduce it I guess
the the bill that's being
um there's a bill to reduce yeah to
reduce it like in three years from 8 and
a half% to
6% so what why why not just keep it at 8
and a half percent why do we need to
reduce it down to
6% you're getting less money now but yet
you're going to you want to put another
fee on this and if you're allowing the
fee how am I go how am I going to
explain to my guests then that I had to
add an additional
10% fee to their bill so we can pay for
for um Services out there just keep it
at 8 half percent but make sure that
it's being administered correctly back
into the towns like I know the 200 Grand
that the town of Bristol gets it just
goes onto the general fund and it's used
used followup yes followup so reducing
the meal and rooms
tax doesn't necessarily hurt you but it
wouldn't it help your business if that
tax was
lowered no because it's a pass through
people don't get upset about that I mean
it's they're used to seeing that that
tax on there so you're saying an
additional tax on their bill might be
alarming right particularly like I said
if you're giving the towns and
municipalities the power to set that fee
they could go anywhere like somebody
said a $2 per room per
night they could go up but there's no
cap on it you could have it $10 10% $100
got it thank you very much oh you're
welcome
so representative spillsbury thank you
Mr chairman in an attempt to reconcile
those comments and take them one step
further what if we combine the concept
of reducing the meals and rooms tax in
terms of its Statewide
application from 8 and a half% take it
down by one or
2% but then concominant
allow local municipalities to sech
charge the meals and rooms tax by that
one two% so that it would not in any
event be higher than the 8 and a half%
it's at now why not just keep it at
eight and a half percent why do you why
do you need an EXT add an extra ST so
today as you pointed out all of the
meals and rooms go into the general fund
but we ear earmark
30% for for distribution back to uh
municipalities those are distributed
across the state regardless of where the
meals and rooms revenues were generated
so what I'm asking is if we reduce the
rate by one or maybe
2% and we then allow a municipality to
surcharge using the exact same
collection structure statutory
scheme um and and make up that
difference then it would return it to
the town of origin that's the difference
so would I be required well how would
they enforce that
D so am I going to if I if you're going
to reduce it say by 2% to 6 and a
half% then you want the town to make up
that
2% how are they going to enforce that on
me as the person collecting that tax
well these are details we'd have to work
out right but just for the sake of
discussion assume that uh the Statewide
figure is 7 and A2 rather than 8 and A2
assume each municipality is given the
enabling legislation to sech charge up
to
1% assume that the state collects it and
they manage it the cash flow and they
rebate the 1% because they know exactly
where it derived from so the records are
all there they just simply have to cut a
check for the 1% It goes back to the
town of origin would would that be
workable for the lodging industry again
I just think it's unnecessary to have
that extra step in there just keep it at
8 and a half% and have it as a pass
through to to my to my guests that stay
with
me what's so hard about that why do why
do we need to add that extra step in
there okay we'll take this up in the
work session yeah that's what I was just
thinking thank you okay thank you very
you okay next is John colban uh no not
okay
okay uh okay the next uh speaker is
Marvel I am Bill Marvel um most of my
thunder has been stolen as well um but I
did want to to uh point out that uh I
viewed this uh I I regard this uh Bill
only and I I know it only in concept and
I support the concept um but I regard it
as a
u an opportunity uh to correct a
longstanding
Injustice um we on the Conway budget
committee uh have tried to figure out
exactly how much money uh Conway
businesses provide to the state through
rooms and muls taxes and have had a hard
time finding that number but by
extrapolating from county numbers and
from Conway's uh prominence uh in that
county uh it's obvious to us that we get
only a small fraction of what we
generate um so I was somewhat uh uh
attracted to the discussion um that just
happened but um the the bill itself
strikes me as as simple fairness we uh
we in
Conway um pay basically for the impact
of the uh industry that provides so much
money to the state and we get very
little of it um and that that really is
you all right uh final pink card I have
is um and I apologize I can't read this
clearly it's
Co sorry I did scribble there at the end
uh so I'm uh from Conway as well and I'm
uh grappling between sitting here as a
citizen or sitting here as the chairman
of the the planning board because I am
the chairman of the planning board for
the town of Conway and as Paul said
earlier we have approved quite a few
hotels in the recent
years and recently last year we proposed
a moratorium on building hotels and um
commercial structures of 50,000 square
foot or greater
because we need to and we're putting it
back on the warrant again this year um
we need to
because we just we're at a loss as to
what to do to to help our citizens to
help the people who live and work in
Conway to help people like me I'm a
bluecollar guy I took the day off to
come down here I have family I got kids
you know it's it's not easy for somebody
like me to get down here I think I
represent a large portion of the
population of New Hampshire who can't
come to these but I really wanted to
come down and speak to this um the the
reason we're proposing the moratorium
and it's it's funny that the Lodging
Association lady who's not here who who
left she brought up um liy or die right
as a planning board member people often
ask me why do we need another hotel why
did you let them do why did you let them
build another well we have to we follow
the rsas we do things properly as we
should well
Freeport they um they have a cap on gas
stations they can't build any more gas
stations in Freeport one in one out
that's it well free port's Maine that's
a different state Maine gave their
citizens the freedom to vote that
in all right well what's with our
lodging what can you do if you go to New
Hampshire zoning Atlas and you look at
new H at Conway we are one of the most
permissive towns for um for for housing
for long-term rentals for we are trying
every Avenue we are offering density
bonuses we are offering incentives we
are trying as hard as we can to make it
a livable area for families to thrive in
well what about uh J Peak J Peak they um
they built housing for their workers
well J peaks in Vermont Vermont allowed
their citizens the freedom to vote that
in this is just an option for to help me
help the the taxpayers the guys at the
bottom yeah it's not going to solve all
the problems it's a little bit that
helps you asked what would help a time
machine would help because New Hampshire
sat on hands for way too long about
short-term rentals it has completely
destroyed the assessments up in Conway
it's it's insane what we're dealing with
because I live in a community that's
half empty all the time now I I was born
and raised in Conway the community I
lived in used to thrive it was the place
where we would all the all my friends
lived now every other house is empty
most of the week because they're
short-term rentals those houses were
purchased way over value and it's it's
just a mess I mean this is insane to me
that it doesn't feel like there's a lot
of support for this it's two I mean I
heard $2 there was that I think that was
a great the 2% back um but nobody in
this room would cancel a 7day stay for
$14 a night if it was $2 a
night it's just I don't understand what
we're doing to help the taxpayers in the
state of New Hampshire it seems like
there is a constant drum being beat for
business business business but where's
where's the representation for people
like me I'm struggling and we had the
police chief who makes way more money
than I do saying that he couldn't afford
his home you think I can afford mine I
bought it probably four years before he
did so we were very fortunate when we
bought our house it got evaluated at
almost half a million dollars and it has
the original Kitchen in it that was
built in
1970 okay it's not a half a million
dollar home but the market is so messed
up and we are just looking for ways for
a little relief we need we need the we
need the services we need the sewer we
need Town Water and Sewer if we want to
put more housing in we need that for
density we need to increase those lines
through town we need ways to pay for
that um we need to increase the police
force because of what we're dealing with
with the tourists you know whether or
not this gets passed or not Portsmith
still needs a ladder truck and you know
Hampton still needs police police you
know officers and that's just going to
continue to fall on the backs of people
like me and I just really hope that you
are all willing to do the work on this
bill there seems to be a lot of places
where it needs to be you know
strengthened up and and reassured that
this money is being used properly and
does help the budgets where it can I I
thank you for letting me speak and I'm
sorry I got a little worked up but I I I
just I was born in New Hampshire I love
New Hampshire and you know just trying
to do what I can thank you thank you
GNA have questions if you want to remain
seated okay one uh yes go ahead thank
you Mr so what does the average family
in Conway need what does the average
blue collar worker and or blue collar
small business owner need to survive
what what do you think the problem is
let me
rephrase how do we solve the problem as
you perceive
it well it's
it's it's it there's no magic bullet
solution there's there's only little
ways to help from every angle and that's
what I hope that this do this doesn't
seem like a big ask it really doesn't a
couple dollars a night does not sound I
don't know anybody that would turn down
a vacation you know you're talking about
going away for a long weekend then
someone says it's going to cost you6
extra dollars what are you going to say
you going to say no not going to go now
say all right I'll pay six I'll pay 10
want to get away for the weekend so you
support you support that fee idea I I
support the fee idea I do support the
the reduction in the um in in the rooms
and meals with the 2% being able to go
back to the town it's just finding ways
to even the playing field I guess um a
lot of people often say in Conway to me
as as a chairman now I'm speaking as a
chairman of the planning board you know
how can how can how can how why doesn't
why won't the tour how can we get the
tourists to
pay their share to pay to help burden
the costs of all these things so you
know making sure that the roads are
cleared and that the poth holes are
filled and those all the fire calls that
we have and you you know the the police
department needing the the support they
need
so you know I don't know what the
solution is to make it better like make
it all the way fixed I do feel that um
you know what what does a blueco collar
worker need they need a roof over their
head they need a place to live you know
I have friends who grew up with me who
were born the same town as me and they
moved to Brownfield Maine because it's
you know it's a little bit more of a
drive but it's they can live there
because it's not a tourist destination
and the the housing market what didn't
get out of control
um I I don't
know exactly
what the what the solution is you know I
feel like maybe now I'm rambling but I I
just I came down here to to to say my
peace and to you know implore everybody
to to help work on these solutions for
the citizens of New Hampshire um I I
don't think this is I I don't see how
anybody loses from this it's and
municipalities have the right to vote it
in vote it out you know I think that's
the solution when it comes
to um communities and working together
if you
I joined the planning board in Conway in
2017 I was 34 and I was naive I didn't
realize how long it took to make change
I wanted to make sure that so my father
he's here he's he's on the select board
he was born in Conway his father was
born in the valley as well I was born in
Conway and my kids were born in Conway
and I wanted to make sure that Conway
was a place that could continue to have
families and and one of the big things
that I was admitted on is what are we
doing about short-term rentals well it
was wait you know it's before the state
let's not make a decision till the state
does and that didn't pan out well for us
um now it's certainly you know it it's
it's hard to care so much about
something that you have so little
control over and as I stayed on the
planning board for my three-year turn I
reran I was elected chair I'm the chair
of the planning board now when I joined
the planning board our meetings were on
average you know 40 minutes long and it
was mostly we have these hearings for
commercial development we hear them we
approve them we move on you know they
meet the the zoning RS and our meetings
now are regularly 4 hours five hours
long and that's because we're having
conversations we are talking about these
things we are trying to find solutions
that work for everybody and often times
those Solutions are wealthy a Butter's
not happy and the developer not happy I
guess that's the solution like if nobody
nobody's Happ I don't know it's we we
are just trying to work through as much
of this as we
can but we don't we don't have there's
our hands are tied with some of the rsas
like I stated before about you know what
other states are allowed to do and
calling States like Massachusetts
taxachusetts isn't fair Massachusetts is
a beautiful state there's a lot to
admire there's a lot to admire in every
state around us I love New England love
New Hampshire there's
just a lot that we can look to in other
states and say they're doing it right
and there's some people that come before
the planning board and they say well
this isn't this isn't uh Manchester it's
not Manchester but maybe Manchester's
doing it better you know this isn't
Rhode Island well okay it's not Rhode
Island you're right but let's look at
what works in certain places and not
stand on our Laurels so much that we're
you know cutting off our nose despite
our face it's it's frustrating sometimes
um but I'm here here because I care and
I know that you are all here because you
care as well it's being a public servant
I've found is a very thankless job and
it takes a lot of time so um that's
that's all thank you thank you very much
I'm sure we're gonna think hard on this
one so I hope you
do um quickly yes represent fellows um
you talked about there being a lot of um
homes in your neighborhood that are
empty during the week and there are
people there just on the
weekends it yeah so are those people who
own those homes and only show up for the
weekends or are they being rented for
the weekend both there's primarily
there's um short-term rentals I don't
know the owners are actually um you know
out of state somewhere and they're just
on one of the local listings the Airbnb
or verbo vbo or um there was a couple
there's one across the street very nice
couple they they do come up and use
their own home they don't red out and I
that Mr chair yes yeah very briefly as a
former planning board chair I sympathize
and con commiserate with most of your
comments thank you uh these are genuine
predicaments can we agree though that
this bill might address the need to
raise funds for emergency services like
police and fire but it would not address
the genuine problem you've identified
regarding short-term
rentals yes absolutely and as I stated
before no one solution is going to
address every problem I we don't live in
that
world right
exactly
much yes represented Al
me just address something that came up
that most of you don't know about yet is
it something we should address in work
session or is it something to mention
now on I think it would be useful to
mention it now because the head of
restaurant and lodging is here okay uh
we um a number of years ago a brami and
major and I were on a commission with
the Senate whereby the Senate Port
Portsmouth people were trying to on use
the to divert the money from the rooms
and meals tax to the communities that it
came from it turned out that this was
totally impossible to do because on the
um we had passed many years before it
the ability for on owners of
multiple on restaurants to file all of
them as one tax filing
and they were frequently filed even by a
accountant who didn't live in the same
town with the owner so the accountant's
address was on
it so that there is no way at this point
to
identify where that money came from when
it gets to
Dr and um I believe the restaurant and
Lodging Association has been making sure
we don't change that again
okay thank you thank
you all right is there anyone else who
has not testified not filled out a pink
card but wants to
testify okay seeing none I'll close the
uh yeah everything's Tak I
know
okay
Oneal right yeah I know it is what it is
um I only have three for this one so I
okay um in interest of time excuse me we
have uh only three pink cards here um
representative
um Tim MCU MCU okay we'll introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon hungry members of the
committee thanks for Soldier ring on to
the last bill of the day I'll try to
keep it brief I asked for 5 minutes I'll
try to keep it to two and a half um I
just emailed you all my written
testimony so I won't read or recite that
uh in interest of time I'll just focus
on the on the high points yeah it's a
pretty simple Bill 1% reduction in the
meals and rooms tax restore the New
Hampshire
Advantage help Working
Families make the price of a Happy Meal
back under 10
bucks
right Massachusetts is six and a
quarter Connecticut is six something
6.35 Massachusetts has a local option to
increase up to seven a full disclosure
on that meals and rooms tax has been um
oh by the way this targets just the
meals portion and keeps the towns whole
so the bill structured such that it sets
a
floor uh a minimum dispersement to the
towns and it keeps their 30% whole so
this money comes out of the state
piece everybody with me so far or all
your blood sugars are less than
20 okay so anyways that's that's what
this bill does uh there's a fiscal note
on it it's difficult to determine the
exact costs uh meals and rentals tax has
been trending above plan a recent period
uh we were over double it was 72 million
collected on 36 of plan more recently
it's been right about at plan uh and
actually even a few pennies behind plan
but these are traditionally slower
months for those uh for that particular
tax so the cost of this is uh less than
the current Surplus and Le less than the
recent surpluses generated by meals and
Rental tax so this is money straight
back into the pockets of the people who
need it most and I know it's only sounds
like 1% but the average household spends
about 4,000 bucks a year eating out so
this makes a differ difference it
certainly makes a psychological
difference when your Bill's 998 versus
109 or 1010 or something like that you
know times three four kids and parents
and whatnot so it really makes a
difference so my belief is that this
will actually stimulate that economy the
servers and waiters and waitresses are
likely to benefit from better tips
remember the old double the tax when it
was seven and a half and you get 15% it
was an easy way to tip most of us I
think tip more than that now but I think
a little more disposable income will
actually keep people eating inside New
Hampshire not going south and may eat
out just a little more often and that's
good for everybody that increases our
gross domestic product well you all know
the economics of it
so I will dispense with reading there's
some charts and graphs in here you can
read at your Lea Ledger it's in your
email the Kirk clerk has a hard copy
happy to take questions and just to
clarify it does keep the the town's
whole so this money comes out of our
piece and it's meals only because the
thinking is with my finance co-sponsors
and my ways and means
co-sponsor um that we're just fine
collecting the rental uh rooms and car
rental taxes from the out ofate visitors
and that 1% wouldn't make too much of a
difference there so okay thank you uh
represent PL did you have a question we
had two questions one Dre was just
generated supposedly have a hard copy
I'm buried in paper here where do I have
it I think I just put it on your your
desk right right behind your name plate
maybe oh yeah said I'm buried in paper
it says clerk copy at the top I think if
that's I guess the second question was
obviated because you say it's only meals
not RS as written it's currently targets
just meals okay I had a question whether
you would allow a local option but since
it doesn't provide for room reduction
well it's the committee's bill now and I
certainly heard some interest in local
option uh not my preference but my
preference is a straight tax reduction
of about 30 million straight to the
taxpayers of New Hampshire uh but other
states actually I think probably the
majority of other states in my research
do have uh locally
enacted uh sales taxes taxes on meals
and rooms and things and I'll share with
one of the other folks uh who told a
story it is my least favorite thing to
see a 15% city tax or 12% city tax when
I you know rent a hotel room somewhere
uh that that makes me dislike that
particular City it feels very personal
somehow when it's the state it's a
little less personal um but if youve
rented a room in New York or Chicago or
La Chicago is I think the one of the
highest you know what I'm talking about
thank
you representative spillsbury yes so to
follow with the obvious question in
light of the conversation on the last
bill which you were here to hear and
your observation regarding Massachusetts
and other states using a local option uh
if the committee took your bill and
amended it so that it covered meals and
rooms but had an offsetting local option
would you recognize your baby and still
want to keep it or would you become an
opponent it's a great question and thank
you for your question and your
thoughtfulness on it um and I know the
committee will deliberate it uh as will
finance so originally as in as first
drafted it was for both
and some input from at least one Finance
co-sponsor um you know convinced me to
Target meals so since I believe it's
going to go to finance you have a
preview of at least one of their members
opinions on
it
so represent
Aly yes well I was just trying to ask
you is this bill actually
early um my records show that none of
our bills are early yeah don't usually
send things to finance and this is a
problem when you don't have a budget
year uh I wanted to ask you
on
if you realize that the Surplus that
we've built up is quite unusual and is
going
down
and uh the business taxes just went down
almost 10% this month last month
December
um
whether the idea that we could take all
of this out of surplus
isn't something that might not survive
for very
long thank thank you for your comments
representative Aly I'm keenly aware of
the status of the Surplus and follow it
pretty closely um I'm also incredibly
aware aware of inflation and where it's
been up and down a bit and the most
common thing that I hear from my
constituents is how am I going to put
food on the table and gas in the tank
and that's a direct quote uh from
numerous constituents but one of the
very first I encountered uh recent
recently but it's one of the biggest
concerns so I know it's a small amount
but I think it's meaningful and there's
a reason that marketers price things at
9.98 or you know instead of 10 $10 and
change so but thank you for your
comments yeah do you have any
suggestions on what programs we should
remove from the state budget
no thank you representative
fellows thank you Mr chair um you you
said that this tiny cut would make it
easier for some people to put food on
the table and you also said that that
you know that your constituents are
talking about like you know how can they
afford
food um what we heard for the last bill
and what I hear is people saying I can't
afford to live in my house because the
property taxes are too high and I'm
wondering since we're looking at um the
money from the meals tax not not the
rooms that's a separate issue this just
covers from the meal and what we use
that money for we give 30% to the
municipalities to help them you know
it's unrestricted money and do you think
if people are as I believe um are most
concerned about property taxes and also
the price of housing that they might be
better served to not count cut the rate
and instead give
maybe 50% or more of that money to the
municipalities and that that would
better serve your constituents I wonder
what town you're from uh marac uh of 33
years in marac thank you for your
comments and I believe that our
constituents are concerned about all of
their their entire tax burden and every
dollar helps every dollar back to their
disposable income helps them put food on
the table whether it's from the grocery
store or elsewhere you know people a lot
of people buy prepared meals from the
grocery store they're working families
working two jobs get home late they pick
up the I do it on the way home from here
pick up the $6 meal from Market Basket
they're pretty good you should try them
uh but it's a great way you know for if
you're working managing a time schedule
and people are keenly aware of the tax
on those because that those meals are
taxed as you know when you go through
the checkout so I think our constituents
um are concerned about their entire tax
bill and every little bit helps and no I
wouldn't encourage you um uh to send
more a 50% allocation and the details
you mentioned are all are all in the
bill actually uh if you take take a look
through it you'll see it's it
specifically addresses the 30% keeping
the towns whole with minimum but so I
think every bit every tax reduction
helps and U just to Circle back to
representative aly's question about
which programs I would cut uh that'd be
a long answer and we' we're already over
two hours behind so the simple answer
answer is is no off the top of my head I
I'm not going to name my top five least
favorite programs uh but there's more
than five and I I know that this
committee is more than capable of
finding
them uh representative
ery thank you representative for taking
my question um you indicated that you
were splitting this uh so that you were
um segregating out meals for verus rooms
and rentals sort of um that would
require a change in dr's computerization
program did you calculate into that the
cost to administer a change of that
magnitude thank you representative ery I
I do believe the fiscal note mentions
that that they had have to change a form
and update some electronic submission
process and I think they indicated
specifically uh that that cost would be
negligible and absorbed in their current
budget I think it's buried in the very
lengthy fiscal note it's on
uh uh maybe
page
four of the fiscal note in that area it
does say it in there it's a minimal
adjustment
um oh okay but but it does mention it
they do take that into account and I'll
find it for you in a second I think it
said uh somewhere in there it does say
oh yeah actually the very last on page
five additional administrative costs
that could uh or could not be absorbed
uh see oh thank you and another question
sir follow up okay um this is kind of a
theoretical question but um I've noticed
that the cost of going out for breakfast
has gone up a $10 breakfast is now $20
with
tip at my local Diner um so eight and a
half this for the purchaser 8 and a
half% of $20 is X
but 7 and a half% of a $40 meal would be
X
Plus so if it cost you less in the tax
you have more money to spend on the meal
or you could get a big better meal for
the same dollar value is that a correct
analysis of your spending pattern there
we go
oh I'm I'm not sure I know we eat out
less due to due to the cost due to the
cost of it for sure uh I I know that we
go to you know one Diner that charges
you know eight bucks for an omelet
versus 15 um but I your math is probably
sound I I don't know we'll I'll defer to
maybe the uh one of the accountants on
the committee to work some of those
models but there's certainly a lot of
ways to work the numbers Patty went no
Patty went to work with the secretary of
state perap of uh ORS is thank you well
qualified thank you Mr chair
representative elberger thank thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um I would like to know I mean
you said that you mentioned that your
constituents are concerned about the
high cost of food every mine are too and
I would like to know how you would
answer a question from one of my
constituents or yours who might say
thank you for the 50 per 50 cents off my
restaurant bill
my property tax bill has gone up
$500 great question what what would you
suggest that we say reducing property
taxes thank you for your question yeah
this is not the time for debate thank
you m representative shamard thank you
Mr chairman thank you representative of
taking this question you just happened
to mention that you reduce property
taxes but looking at the the charts that
the Dr has provided it indicates that if
you
reduce the uh
M&R it's going to reduce the amount that
goes to public goes to education
fund how do we make that up if
it so so I believe when you reduce that
and make it cheaper more people will eat
out more often
right follow up right and that and that
numerator goes up and is that a
theoretical or is that a data do you
have a data on that that proves that
point there's reams of data and it is a
fairly generally accepted economic
principle of how to increase gross dtic
gross domestic product I mean I think we
don't want to go into econ 101 here but
but I but it's a fairly widely accepted
principle um it doesn't always work
right I mean it's it's hard to predict
exactly what the Market's going to do on
a given day and you know whether we're
going to have a pandemic or a war or
whether we want you know those those
sorts of things
right and I'm not an economist nor an
accountant uh point of order uh
representative ORS you are a
co-sponsor so you can't ask questions
you can testify or ask questions one or
the other right so if you want to be
sitting in your seat like you are you
can just well he can ask questions if he
doesn't testify right no isn't it a
choice no no okay no the choice is you
you can sit out there or sit here but if
you sit here you can't can't ask
enough no
no during the work session during the
work session you can make statements all
right representative PL I just want to
thank the chair first for shutting
up you don't have to sit next to him
yeah Sirus more serious uh comment if if
the state were to reduce the uh room of
meals tax wouldn't that just give room
for the restaurants to raise their
prices
more I hope not I don't know where where
they are um hopefully
not all right do we have any other
questions for representative M no seeing
none thank you very
much all right
next
um
question I was
just
okay well maybe we can get it at a later
time uh okay next is uh
Hy heck okay
yeah
sure good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Katherine heck I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
in the 234 cities and towns in New
Hampshire and I am not here to comment
on some of the policy of House Bill 1515
as whether or not it's a legislative
prerogative to reduce the tax itself I
am here to affirm that we are we
appreciate that the sponsors considered
keeping the municipal piece intact um at
the 20 129 million or 30% whichever is
greater we appreciate that and that the
meals and rooms tax well has been stated
is unrestricted funds that go into our
general fund I did provide you all a
handout a long sheet that talks about
the property tax and how it's set and on
the back of that sheet it is coming
around I
apologize it's
coming
um I will draw your attention to how the
tax rate is set and it is recorded meals
and rooms revenue is recorded as revenue
and therefore directly reduces the tax
rate so if there's a question in your
minds as to how towns are using those
funds it is recorded as revenue and has
to reduce the tax rate as per the dr's
tax formula I also have a handout that
goes into a little detail on the history
of meals and rooms and thank you
representative Al for your comments on
the prior bill but we have enjoyed since
the law change in 2021 a significant
increase in fact a cumulative increase
of $145 million being returned based on
the new formula from 2017 to 2021 the
legislature budgeted as is your
responsibility $ 68.8 million and since
the law change now that it's based on
30% we saw that number go to 100 million
and 22 to 120 million to 130 million so
those are significant dollars that have
come back to taxpayers to reduce the
local property tax so I really did want
as you deliberate the bill and the
merits of this change to just consider
um ensuring that we preserve the missal
portion and that while I understand
based on the previous Bill there was a
lot of discussion
around local options and where some of
the monies are collected but they aren't
maintained this does provide an
equitable way to give back to all of New
Hampshire cities and towns and it does
go back to 1967 so populationbased meals
and rooms um is something that we would
like to preserve for all our cities and
towns I know my own town has one
restaurant and one Inn so we would never
make up the difference that we are
seeing from the current distribution
formula so I did want you to consider
that and if it pleases the chair I will
leave a copy of the last two years in
detail so you can see of the meals and
rooms distribution by town I can email
it as well so you can see in your
communities what has been given back
directly and been reported on your Ms
434 to reduce your local property tax
yeah I think an email would be great as
well of course sir and I'm happy to take
any
questions do we have any questions yes
representative Bo um no no
you're you can't speak we're yeah we're
still on the same bill
for a second there I thought wait a
aren't we still on the same bill
okay anybody
else seeing none thank you very much um
excuse me Mr CH oh I'm sorry could we
just ask you for some contact
information your your phone number sure
I have provided that to the committee
and I will email the entire committee my
two handouts and my contact information
will be on there um and again I want to
thank the legislature not only for that
law change but for the amount of money
you have been returning to cities and
towns it has been reducing local tax
burdens whether it's in the highway
block rant money the bridge Aid and some
of the other programs that you have
established so thank you very much for
that continued partnership and support
thank
you okay last but not least laureno
Dr
good afternoon chair and members of the
committee my name is Lauren O Sullivan
and I am the senior Financial Analyst at
the Department of
Revenue and I'm Wendy metivier analy at
Revenue and we are here today to um we
do not have a position on the bill and
um we're here today to just discuss any
questions you may have though I would
like to clarify that um this bill is
only impacting the meals portion of the
tax uh the portion of the tax that goes
to the education trust fund is the
rentals or the vehicle portion of the
tax so we do not see an impact on the
education trust fund and what that was
presented by somebody else in the fiscal
notes so we will just be talking about
fund okay um there any questions Wendy
well let me just say Wendy when you get
a chance if you'd pill out a pin card
for this bill when you're done you gave
me one for a different um the last
bill so just for a quing purposes yes
representative fellow so I I had a
question on the last page the
back about the
administration is that money that's
going to Dr
or what so that is money that stays in
the general fund the Dr is a general
funded um agency so that's just the
money that is related to administering
the meals and room and it doesn't
necessarily stay with the Dr but
technically it could if you look at the
way the SOA is
funded
so to follow up to follow up on that I'm
not clear what you're saying is it is it
established as a percentage or how is
that determined this is an annual
calculation that is done based on uh all
the revenue that comes that comes in for
all of the
taxes and then what port and then we
look at the expenditures related to the
administration of um meals and rooms so
it's not every uh part of the Dr
expenses are eligible for the
calculation and then that percentage is
what's used as a set aside to the
general
annually um representative shamber did
you have
a Oh I thought someone else down here
represent
ol
okay
you on back on page four I think it is
of the bill it's it's fairly confusing
and I don't know if we have time to read
the T the text if it it doesn't look
like it becomes less confusing there on
what you're talking about is that
because we'll have to be paying more
from uh in table two more from uh the
[Music]
on from the meals and rooms Revenue
then uh we would at
30% it'll will
Lo yeah
sorry yeah on table
two on I think what you're saying is
that on by the time the tax is f
changed we will lose 12 million a year
for the general fund because we're
paying more than the hund uh we're
paying
129 million and it looks like we'll be
getting less than that at 30% that's
correct so at um this is a static
analysis so that's just based on the the
activity that we in 23 exactly so with
that reduction what how we do that
calculation it will be a reduction to
the general fund but then you have to
fund from
uh from the direct loss of of the uh
percentage of the percentage to
percentage whatever it was of of the
males
tax and and we'll we'll end up losing
from the general fund 53
static that is correct because you have
the impact of the loss from the meals
portion of the tax as well as the
additional funds going to the municipal
fund okay so we do have on 53 million it
wouldn't be 53 +
12 correct that's uh that's in total uh
so I'm sorry let me just reread you're
looking at table
three so yeah so a full year impact
would be 53.2 million to the general
fund due to the decrease as well as that
fund thank you which we'd have to take
um Municipal Association indicated that
there was a direct relationship between
uh State um revenues and revenue sharing
and the town effect but and Town and
County property taxes now I know in my
town it's roughly 6% goes to County it's
it's relatively small
uh portion of it um even in Nash
Manchester it's it's really
small so disc
County the less than 10% that counties
take into consider to take out of your
property
taxes the other property taxes are based
upon School costs and town
Administration costs and of those the
school has direct control over how much
they're taking out of property taxes and
the town has a direct proportion as to
how much they're taking out of property
taxes and how much the state gives to
them has no effect upon how much the
individual towns wish to pay so anything
the state gives is gravy s so as to
speak would that be the right way to uh
or a more correct way to look at the
relationship between State
rebates general term not
specific but just general term to the
towns rather than saying that the the
state has a direct impact upon local
property taxes when it's a addition
to uh local property taxes am I getting
it am I saying that the right way
or I'm thinking I'm understanding the
question um I would have to get back to
you with an answer on that I am not I
not going to pretend to be an expert on
the property tax portion I can reach out
to our Municipal uh
group see if I can you you've been
listening to the White House Press
Conference
co-sponsor I I appreciate you keep
trying but you call Bill
Bo all right does anyone else have any
questions okay thank oh no can't you
can't do
that I'm just can you just tell me these
blocks because I don't understand is
this it does it's not well is this like
the
is so one block is just um isolating the
decrease to the meals portion of the of
the proposal the second block is looking
at the municipal Revenue fund
distribution and the third block is the
changes does that answer your question
or have I confused you so are you you is
this the block here which table are you
referring to is that table one table two
t Okay table two is that current using
where where is if we do nothing usually
I see figures that say if you do nothing
these are the numbers and if you
implement this Bill here's the
difference so um in table two at fiscal
year 25 would be the do nothing option
and that is because the way the
municipal fund transfers is calculated
it's the prior fiscal Year's um results
um goes into the calculation for 25 so
then when the when this tax decrease
goes into effect we're not going to see
that any Municipal Revenue fund until
fiscal year 26 when we use the fiscal
year 25 Revenue results to calculate the
26 Municipal fund transfer amount so the
reason that it goes down from from 129
down to 118 that's the rate cut correct
you're saying okay it's not really um
that cor so what you're seeing in fiscal
26 is the results with the with the rate
cut and can you explain Table Three
also um that is the summary of tables
one and two together because both tables
one and two are impacting the general
fund so what we're showing is that you
have that seven you have that 1%
decrease is going to cause x% decrease
to the general fund just by the nature
of it being a tax decrease and then you
have an
additional amount um that's com out of
the general fund to fund the municipal
Revenue fund transfer portion because uh
this bill is designed to have a floor so
if we don't meet the 100
9.2
million um based on performance we have
to still remit 29.2 million if we do
better than that that's great and the
30% calculation um takes effect but if
the 30% is a lot less then we have the
whole thank you you're welcome okay any
other questions seeing none thank you
very much thank
you is there anyone else who would like
to testify on hp55
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on HP
1515 well that was
uh we're a little bit over maybe by two
hours um so I want to
ask I want to ask everyone um did you
you know in terms of procedure because
now our next two meeting dates are
Tuesday the 16th and Wednesday the 17th
and the schedule is set in a similar way
where I have a bill every half hour
starting at 10 o'clock
um do you do you did you prefer how this
went or would you prefer that we try to
um add a little more time and have a
lunch break um this went longer than
than anticipated I certainly didn't
anticipate it going this long so I like
to hear some feedback um yes represent
ol um this this wasn't that bad but it I
think we need to put some discipline on
ourselves we need to stay focused on the
language of the bill in front of us not
on General topics and we're all guilty
of that
um
and you could do it like the Senate does
half an hour and if you don't like it
too
bad what does that mean well if you go
to the Senate bill they have it at their
time and when the time is over meeting's
over the hearing's over even if
even if people they they shut up I don't
think that would go over well I like the
concept but I don't think it would be a
good idea one thing though is if you've
got a lot of people talking put your
microphone on please sorry if we've got
a lot of people talking and particularly
when what was it six of them are from
Conway yeah on get them all to come
together and on and start telling people
that on you've got two three minutes to
make your
point and then if we got a lot of
questions it gets longer but yeah um
well I I agree with Jordan made a good
point we shouldn't be asking policy
questions of of the people because
because that's where in the work session
we should be discussing those sorts of
things we should be talking about the
specifics um of the bill U
yes I would just like to say that you
know being on I I was on different
committees for the the last two terms
but I I think this always happens when
you the first day that you get back
because everybody you know you just
jumping back into the work and I think
that we so excited about it we just like
want to talk more so I think I think
it'll partly clear itself up yeah some I
mean some of it's the bill some of it um
just trying to
anticipate well there a lot lot of I
never expected HB 1254 to have that many
people talking I mean that totally took
us by surprise because if I knew this
was going to go this long I certainly
would have scheduled a lunch break prior
to this schedule um and maybe you know
we can look at the um the schedule I
have now because by Wednesday I can
change because right now I've got both
those days you know every half hour
again and if it goes nicely you might be
done by 12:30 or maybe 1 and I think
everyone likes that idea because when it
looked like that was possible everyone
elberger is it
permissible um this is my first term so
I'm still trying to figure out is it
permissible to limit testimony to five
minutes and if so can we do that can and
and I'm I'm just going to sort of toss
out a bunch of things can you as chair
say if you more forcefully and I was
really appreciative as we got into the
bill that you said don't repeat um but
just to say to somebody who starts
repeating have you got something
new yes um and I I also
wonder and I I have no idea about the
answer to this one whether it makes
sense to schedule more time and finish a
little bit early
or to just say you know show up and we
may not get to you for an hour after
you're scheduled well so if you so if we
if I schedule an hour and they finish
early I can't start the next one so
that's the theory of doing it every half
hour um and you know like as I said
Tuesday and Wednesday next week are
scheduled that way so potentially I
could leave it like that and then if it
looks like it's going to go long again I
could could take the Pulse of the room
here and see if you want to go to lunch
the the problem is when it's scheduled
that way the people that are here
probably don't really want to go to
lunch they want to get it done so I
could
change I'll I'll get you in a
second um we still have time to change
and so that's what we'll look at in in a
second here is just let's look at that
quickly to see if you want you guys want
me to change the scheduling um
representing flat yes from the clerk's
perspective I get stir crazy after a
while I need the break uh and I need to
sort some of the papers out because I
just get overwhelming here I need some
food in my belly okay yeah so uh I
realized didn't anticipate it going this
long but if it if you do anticipate that
I could appreciate the lunch
speak thank you so yeah I as I think uh
Susan said I would like to I would have
liked to have uh shortened the testimony
of the first uh person and Sally and I
were talking I tried to catch her I
didn't realize she was going to walk out
but we were both had come to that say
she kept repeating herself and and just
kept going on and on and it you know we
took over just over an hour yeah on her
alone and if we had you know somehow
come in even close to 40 minutes we we
could have maybe kept it on I so I think
the answer is I don't care you know what
side of the fence they on I think we
need to shorten that and say look you
got five minutes and if they hit five
minutes or give them four minutes and
then you know if we think it's necessary
give him a couple more minutes but wow
that gal took like forever okay so
there's there's a couple things one is
um and to answer represent Elber
Berger's question in more detail I
believe if and you can correct me if I'm
wrong represent Al me but I believe if
I'm going to limit how long people can
talk I have to start that at the very
beginning and I I I admit when I saw
that big stack I should have from the
beginning just
said I need everyone to limit their
their testimony to three minutes um you
know because I saw and I thought well
we'll see how it goes but then you start
getting deeper into the snack and people
have five minutes on there or whatever
and then it's you you are not I believe
supposed to start saying okay now from
now on we're limiting everyone because
now those you know people feel cheated
five minutes
any well five minutes is still a lot I
mean
I yeah that I know I mean that happens
all the time in all different committees
um I every time that happens I do feel
like saying can you just outline it but
the problem is the person comes
here they they may not be able to
outline it and then they're gonna feel
like so I think we also have to be
careful with our questioning like if
we've got answers there were a few times
where I feel like some of us asked
questions that were answered from
previous speakers I don't think we need
to ask the question again um so I think
there were multiple things there was
only yeah
I think that medical it's important that
we get a lunch break yeah no and I I I
agree but the problem is and I need to
take a menum break after sitting here
for almost four and a half hours but I
think the issue is when I asked everyone
everyone was like yeah let's finish it
up we didn't really realize it would go
this long so now given this experience
you know what should we do for Tuesday
and Wednesday should I increase the
amount of time for each of those not the
seven person who spoke yes represent
Ames I'm not sure about that last
question um I I um I think I I would
strongly
encourage um on any bill that's likely
to take time setting time
limits right at the outset yeah um and
with with some leeway to you in your
discretion if some something is being
said that needs to be fleshed out make
that judgment call I think you're
entitled to do that and then um the
burden is very much on us in this
committee to discipline ourselves on our
questions and uh that's a big part of
the reason we went a long time today
right um so on those two counts but in
terms of uh the time allowed per bill
you do get into this qu of you allow an
hour you know that you may sit around on
your hands for 15 45 minutes yeah um and
so I I guess I might stick with the 30
minutes allow time for lunch if and um
and then we all know that we're going to
go home a little later maybe you know
you look at the set of bills at 30
minutes each and you say oh boy I'm
going to be out of here by 1:00 okay
well we're not going to be but take time
for lunch yeah I don't know whether
other people would agree with that it's
nice to March through these things and
be done but uh um I guess I would
favor a lunch period if if the
calculation of 30 minutes times the
start time okay plus start time yes
represent sburg I know
you I think uh the extent to which
things went over today isn't the norm
and for planning purposes I wouldn't
presume that this repeats itself every
second session yeah um I I agree with
most of the comments that I've already
said about disciplining ourselves and I
think one of the key things is you've
mentioned with several of the bills this
morning that we're going to have a work
session if we could just have a clear
understanding that we all anticipate
that there will in fact be a work
session on every bill then I think it
allows us to be much more restrained in
terms of expressing ourselves during a
hearing um so I I would encourage you to
stick with the schedule you've already
uh
noticed okay yes I I I hesitate to
suggest it but if you uh have a sense
that things might take longer and
sometimes you can sort that out by
what's the topic
um that perhaps we start at 9:30 I am
not a fan of getting up early I'm just
putting it out and also to make clear at
the beginning of the day that that we
will be taking a lunch
break and that way people who are here
for a bill that's later in the schedule
May will understand from the get-go that
they probably won't be speaking until
after the lunch
break yeah I won't I won't know that
from the beginning though that's more
likely to be known you know around 11
11:30 or something we're starting to
fall behind maybe at that point I said
okay we're going to finish up Bill XYZ
potentially
yeah
yeah so real quick uh I like Dick's idea
about limiting the time of the testimony
I like Susan's idea about maybe starting
a half hour earlier I wonder if as she
said based on the topic if we scheduled
some of these for 45 minutes just to put
a little buffer in the schedule maybe
and and last I don't want anybody to
faint but even though I SP co-sponsored
that last bill I I do not think taxation
is theft now what do you think of that
idea now my Democrat friends might
really shock and fall over on that
statement but the other thing that I'm
seeing is and I think we all heard it
today we need to find a way to tax the
tourism more and not the people of New
Hampshire we need to because I've heard
this seven years ago people I knew
friends in BO that were losing their
homes they had to move because of taxes
we're hearing that now so we got to find
a way to tax the tourist industry can't
believe I said that and and not the
people of New Hampshire and I Deni that
a